[Musique]
Bernard Squarcini, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons en direct sur une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Oui, Sky,
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Oh, je suis fonctionnaire français
qui a intégré la police nationale et
plus spécialement le le renseignement
intérieur depuis très longtemps en 1981.
fils de fonctionnaires français dans la
police aussi.
Euh, j'ai choisi cette voix en
connaissance de cause et je l'ai
pratiqué pendant plusieurs années.
Euh, je suis né au Maroc par le hasard
des choses et les carrières de mon père
en 1955. Donc ça vous donne une idée un
petit peu de ce que j'ai eu comme
expérience jusqu'en 2012 où là j'ai été
placé hors cadre, ce qui est prévu dans
le statut des préfets. Et euh après 6
mois, j'ai choisi de développer une
activité dans le privé mais toujours
pour la défense du drapeau français.
C'est quoi un bon flic ?
Un bon flic, on devient flic mais on
finit flic surtout.
C'est ce que disait.
Euh un bon flic, c'est celui qui a le
sens, l'intuition, l'intelligence et
puis qui sait manager ses équipes. Parce
que un tout seul, c'est rien. C'est un
travail d'équipe. On travaille en me
comme la plupart des travaux un peu et
boulot, métier spécialisé.
Si je vous dis de tête si je vous dis le
renseignement c'est un métier de voyou
fait par des seigneurs ou c'est un
métier de roi fait par des truons ?
Ça vous fait penser à qui ?
Oh bien sûr, vous êtes dans le vrai. Je
pense que c'est un métier de
professionnel.
Ça vous fait penser à qui ? Ça me fait
penser à beaucoup de monde qui ont
marqué également le ministère de
l'intérieur.
Mais c'est vous qui devinerez un petit
peu puisque j'ai travaillé sous
l'autorité de plusieurs ministres
gauche, droite et autres.
Et donc je vois à peu près qui était
meilleur que l'autre parce qu'il était
mieux entouré tout simplement et parce
que le renseignement c'est ce qui permet
d'anticiper, c'est ce qui permet
d'éclairer une décision qui est prise
par le politique en toute connaissance
de cause. Ça ne veut pas dire que c'est
le renseignement qui impose la décision.
Non, on est clair, on dit la vérité.
Ensuite, le politique choisit. Mais nous
nous avons éclairé auparavant et en
amont tout les tenants les aboutissants
très longuement avant, c'est-à-dire
avant la crise et lorsqu'on est là pour
donner un avis, on le donne de façon
éclairée pour pouvoir avoir une décision
la plus efficace possible.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la gestion
de la crise Covid par le renseignement
français et des prises de décision de de
l'État français ? Alors, l'ambassade de
France en Chine a fait son job. Elle a
averti en temps réel qu'il y avait des
petits problèmes
sanitaires sur la région de OAN.
Ensuite, c'était peut-être au d'abord à
l'OMS également au niveau international
à l'Europe et ensuite au service
français à aller voir un petit peu et
vérifier ce qui se passait pour lever le
doute. Manifestement, bon, cette affaire
a peut-être été sous-estimée, donc on a
pris du retard.
On a même donné nos masques aux amis
chinois à un moment et donc lorsque la
crise abattu son plein, on en manquait
puisque la doctrine en ce domaine a
largement évolué par une décision du
LGDSN qui a été en 2013 par des rapports
de la Cour des comptes qui étaient bien
avant sous depuis 2011 2013
et le stock de masse qui avait été
généré par les Prusses de Xavier
Bertrand, l'établissement de prévention
et ripost aux urgences sanitaires avait
disparu au fur à mesure et puis aller
vers des destructions puisque seules les
infrastructures vitales qui assurent la
continuité de l'action de l'État et la
population bien sûr
était prioritaire, le reste était laissé
aux employeurs.
Cette crise, c'est vrai qu'elle est
brutale, elle est invisible et elle est
mondiale. Donc un petit virus
déglingue toute une activité économique,
politique, internationale.
Le renseignement dans tout ça. Bon,
est-ce que nous avons d'abord
des gens spécialisés, des experts dans
le domaine sanitaire, le domaine médical
et autres ? J'en doute. On en a eu à un
moment, puis ensuite ce n'était plus je
dirais de mise. Aujourd'hui, je ne sais
pas ce qu'il en est mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu un trou dans la carlingue
et donc un petit trou d'air.
Manifestement,
on a manqué d'anticipation et de prise
en compte de la juste mesure de cette
crise qui s'est avéré très vite brutale
et réelle.
D'où les mesures élémentaires
confinement comme la peste au Moyen-Âge,
le temps de trouver du masque, des tests
peut-être le tracing si besoin était et
ensuite aboutir à un déconfinement le
somum de la crise étant passé par la
surmédicalisation, la
surhospitalisation, ce qu'il fallait
absolument éviter et ça ça a été géré de
façon assez efficace.
Vous parlez de des services de soins qui
étaient érintés, qui recevaient du
matériel de contrefaçon ou qui était
complètement
défectueux. C'est ça.
Les services
ont dû sauter sur tout ce qui existait,
tout ce qui passait sans dans l'urgence
pouvoir vérifier. Ensuite, dans un
deuxième temps, il y a eu des
vérifications, des normes imposées, le
contrôle fait par les douanes et autres.
Donc une rigueur supplémentaire
au moment où la crise était prise en
main, surmontée avec efficacité
puisqu'on a vu que certains malades
étaient du de l'est évacué en Allemagne,
d'autres vers la région bordelaise, de
la Corse vers Marseille. Tous les moyens
ont été mis pour assurer une espèce
d'équilibre dans les entrées des euh
patients. Sur le matériel, c'est vrai
que lorsqu'on voit aujourd'hui que
monsieur Wang chinois va créer un
établissement de fabrication de masques
à Aubervilier,
nous nous avions des super petites
entreprises
dans Bretagne et Hut qui savaient
fabriquer les masques. Bon, vu le
manque, je dirais de commande, vu les
charges sociales et autres, tout ceci a
fermé et aujourd'hui on s'emploie à les
réouvrir. Ça veut dire que revient à
nouveau le phénomène de souveraineté,
souveraineté économique et indépendance
nationale, ce qui a manqué à un certain
moment.
Revenons un peu à la Chine
et les services de renseignement qui
sont censés
illuminer le chemin de la décision de
l'État.
Comment vous expliquez que le 31
décembre le qued d'Orsse est saisi par
l'intermédiaire de de l'ambassadeur de
France en Chine ?
Laurent Billy. Oui.
Euh monsieur Billy et euh et que
derrière
ça a l'air de patiner. En décembre, vous
étiez vous le 31 décembre ?
Bah le 31 décembre, on était en train de
faire la fête.
Bravo.
Euh euh on était en train de faire la
fête avec beaucoup de monde et on était
d'ailleurs en train de faire aussi du
renseignement parce qu'on s'arrête
jamais.
Bien sûr, mais certains mêmes rigolaient
parce que des malades étaient accueillis
dans les couloirs des hôpitaux en Chine,
rappelez-vous.
Oui. Oui. Non mais il commençait déjà à
rigoler parce que il faisait des
hôpitaux en urgence et que
en 10 jours deux hôpitaux. Pas mal.
D'accord. Comment vous expliquez que
l'anticipation de la crise du Covid, la
gestion du Covid soit une des pires
un des pires échecs des services de
renseignement français ?
Pas seulement français, mais je pense de
la communauté.
On se compare pas au dernier de la
classe. Non non non non. Alors, les
Français sont très bons dans le domaine
du renseignement, je vous l'accorde. Il
bénéficient d'une coopération
internationale, qu'elle soit européenne
ou je dirais internationale.
Anticiper les révolutions arabes.
Non,
c'est ça que vous appelez très bon.
Les révolution arabes, c'est un autre
sujet sur lequel il a fallu courir, je
dirais, et être à la remorque des
événements. Je suis entièrement
d'accord. Ce qui était très important
pour nous dans la mesure où on a perdu
toutes nos sentinelles d'outre
Méditerranée qui permettai de d'assurer
une sécurité maximale de notre
territoire national parce que nous
avions d'excellentes relations avec ces
services d'où allaient venir tous nos
malheurs. Pour revenir à la crise et les
services de renseignement, oui, il faut
avoir de l'expertise.
Est-ce que nous l'avions en terme
sanitair, médical, docteur,
chercheur et autres ? Je ne sais pas.
Mais aujourd'hui, c'est en voie d'être
rattrapé. Mais travailler sur la Chine,
ce n'est pas la même façon que d'aller
travailler au Sahel ou dans une autre
pays d'Europe. Il est certain que c'est
beaucoup plus difficile. Et puis et puis
la Chine n'était pas une priorité, soit
dans le domaine économique bien sûr,
mais pas sur le plan sanitaire.
Deuxièmement, on avait coopéré pour
l'installation d'un P4 dans le style de
Lyon à une grande époque inauguré
ensuite par monsieur Casneu et autres.
Laboratoire P4 pour nos auditeurs.
C'est laboratoire P4.
Mais dès qu'on a livré Clé en main,
l'appartement témoin, on n plus droit au
quelconque contrôle.
Deuxièmement, les services chinois sont
bien plus nombreux que nous, bien plus
offensifs et ont une série de petites
mains qui sont là pour nous infiltrer,
acquérir du renseignement de façon
offensive.
C'est quoi offensif ?
Offensif, c'est faire de la pénétration,
de l'entrisme et avoir des sources
humaines,
c'est-à-dire verrouler des universités à
Brest.
Alors là, on est dans le statut des
pseudoétudiants chinois. Moi-même,
lorsque j'ai été responsable de la DCRI,
j'avais attiré l'attention pour qu'on
limite le nombre de visas étudiants
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
cherchaient mais très peu qui
trouvaient.
C'est la définition du chercheur, non ?
Ah, c'est comme la police, ça cherche
mais ça trouve aussi. Donc le chercheur,
il y avait les vrais chercheurs et puis
les chercheurs qui étaient là sous
couverture scientifique comme ils
peuvent être sous couverture
journalistique
et qui cherchai Ah bah oui, ça existe
également ce domaine et qui était là
pour remplir une mission mais il est
vrai que ils ont le nombre avec eux par
rapport à ce que nous nous pouvons
apporter. Deuxièmement, notre système
est beaucoup plus libéral que le leur et
quand on va en Chine, on est vite pris
en compte par les différents services.
Donc pour un agent, il est assez
difficile de pouvoir travailler
librement et de façon aisée comme dans
d'autres pays.
Un agent un agent en Chine, il s'expose
à quoi ? Une surveillance numérique, une
surveillance physique
totale ?
C'est quoi ?
Et puis en période de confinement,
comment vous faites
en période de confinement
? La période chinoise pendant laquelle
tout ceci s'est déclaré, plus personne
ne circulait. Le régime politique
central était venu gérer le pouvoir
régional avec son pouvoir militaire et
policier. Ce qui rend tout à fait
difficile le moindre contact qui en plus
était faisait l'objet d'une surveillance
extrême, qu'elle soit informatique,
téléphonique ou autre ou humaine.
Est-ce que Est-ce que la Chine fait
d'autres pénétrations en France ? Bien
sûr, mais comme d'autres pays.
On va demander à la femme de ménage
juste de de à l'homme de ménage
d'ailleurs de de se détendre un peu.
Elle va se calmer dans 2 secondes. J'ai
l'ingénieur du son qui qui est en train
de de nous
vibrionner.
Donc le le C'est bon, ça passe pour le
micro. Impeccable. Bon euh revenons à la
Chine. La Chine nous nous fait quel type
de pénétration sur notre propre
territoire ? Est-ce que la Chine utilise
ces téléphones portables de certaines
marques pour prendre avec l'objectif du
téléphone portable une photo de gens qui
seraient en contact avec des Chinois
depuis le territoire français ou des
choses comme ça ?
D'abord, la Chine a un développement
économique, technique, scientifique
assez poussé. Regardez la 5G
aujourd'hui, ce sont les seuls à pouvoir
proposer
euh cette technique, cette technologie.
Les Américains on ont pris ombrage, les
Anglais ont dit oui. La France a dit oui
mais sauf à Paris, sauf à Toulouse.
Pourquoi Toulouse ? Parce qu'il y a un
gros pôle aéronautique. Bref, bah parce
qu'on a nos sous-marins nucléaires,
lanceur d'argent, notre force nucléaire.
Longue
longue. Et donc on a dit oui mais il y a
des limites. La 5G représente un atout.
Certains donc ils ont une avance
technologique et les Américains disent
tous ceux qui vont
prendre en compte cette technique seront
blacklistés puisque laissez-nous en gros
rattraper l'année de retard qui nous
manque et ensuite on pourra jouer d'égal
à égal puisqu'il est certain que les
sources techniques représentent un pôle
très important d'une activité de
renseignement.
Les Chinois ont cette technique
d'avance. Ils ont la quantité de main
d'œuvre pour pouvoir acquérir du
renseignement.
La technique du bac à sable, c'est ça ?
Oui. Et puis aussi,
c'est pourquoi la technique du bac à
sable ?
Tout est bon. Tout est bon. Le moins, si
vous voulez, c'est en gros, on va vous
envoyer une centaine d'agents. Même s'il
en reste un, c'est celui qui va
décrocher la timbale. Nous, on en aura
un. Et si on se plante et ben il nous
reste plus rien. Si en plus vous
rajoutez ce que l'on a réussi à mettre
un petit peu sous les noir une rivalité
entre service de renseignement français
mais on va pas aller loin. Donc il
fallait pour nous d'abord coordonner
notre action, la mutualiser et ensuite
faire face aux différentes attaques qui
peuvent être très sympathiques. n'est
plus autant de la guerre froide, mais il
faut savoir que depuis la guerre froide,
les le nombre des résidents, enfin le
nombre des des agents ont augmenté, ont
doublé. La fin de la guerre froide a
marqué quand même une une réaction et un
regain de l'activité d'espionnage,
mais qui évolue. Avant, c'était plutôt
du militaire, du tactique, du
stratégique. Aujourd'hui, on est dans de
l'économique et du simplement politique.
Est-ce qu'ils envoient des irondelles ?
Comment
est-ce qu'ils envoient des irondelles ?
Oh, il y a les irondelles plus les N qui
vont avec. Ça veut dire qu'ils sont chez
nous et ils y restent et ils font euh je
dirais ce que tout service de
renseignement fait ailleurs.
Ça veut dire quoi envoyer des irondelles
? Ben, ils envoient, je dirais, euh des
émissaires euh et autres pour approcher
euh la mouvance qui va bien et ensuite
on voit par quel degré et par quelle
orientation on peut approcher et
acquérir en un certain nombre de mois ce
que l'on recherche. Donc, on est sur des
gens qui sont très gentils au demeurant
hein, c'est pas un problème.
Gentil ou focus ? Oh, les deux mais on a
du dent mais ça fait partie du système.
Bon, vous croyez que nous on est
toujours aussi gentil ou offensif et
tout ? Bah, ça dépend euh le domaine
d'activité d'une part, mais également la
personne que vous approchez. Et là, ils
ont une panoplie de méthode. Mais quand
vous êtes ingénieur chez d'Asso, que
vous travaillez sur le rafale, que vous
allez en Chine,
c'est pas parce que vous laissez votre
ordinateur dans le coffre de l'hôtel qui
va pas être pompé et que si vous
utilisez le wifi de l'hôtel, ils en
sauront autant que vous. Et puis si au
moment du dîner ou l'après-diner, après
votre repas d'affaires, une superbe
créature vous tombe dessus, faut pas
croire que vous êtes redevenu un donjant
en 5 minutes.
Est-ce que les périmètres des futures
épouses des ingénieurs à Brest sont
faits par la DCI ? À votre avis ?
C'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça. Si
vous voulez, lorsque vous touchez à des
domaines relevants du secret défense ou
du confidentiel défense puisque le
domaine évolue, vous faites l'objet
d'une enquête d'habilitation.
À partir de là, vous rayonnez
sur tous vos collatéraux, vos
ascendants, vos descendants et vous
faites une enquête complète sur une
durée d'une année. Donc on vous passe au
TAMI.
exemple, votre grand-père ou je sais pas
moi a fait l'objet d'une approche par un
copain qui était en Russie à une grande
époque et tout, il a fait partie d'un
voyage, je dirais touristique
sur Moscou et autres à une autre époque.
On va s'y intéresser.
Ça veut pas dire que mais si vous
voulez, il faut lever le doute parce
qu'aujourd'hui,
je vais récupérer monsieur Sky en le
tamponnant.
Par qui ?
Un agent qui vient vous voir, qui vous
prend parce que vous avez un profil
intéressant.
Mais je vais vous exploiter dans 10 ans,
pas aujourd'hui. Parce que dans 10 ans,
vous aurez progressé dans un domaine qui
vous est cher. Et dans 10 ans, on va se
retrouver par le hasard des choses. Les
gens il y voler mais tout ceci est
planifié. C'est pas c'est pas fait au
petit au petit hasard. On va revenir sur
le Covid juste après, mais on va parler
contre-espionnage parce que la la DCI
est censée faire du contre-espionnage.
C'est un service de renseignement et de
sécurité. Oui.
Et aussi de propagande et de
contrepropage.
Non, la des séries fait pas de
propagande.
Absolument pas.
Jamais.
De la sensibilisation, c'est pas pareil.
D'accord, on s'est bien compris.
Donc imaginez-vous, on veut me tamponner
mais est-ce que on est plus intelligent
et on va créer les conditions pour
pouvoir les doubles tamponner nous les
Français parce qu'on a compris qu'on
voulait se faire tamponner et qu'on fait
un honn.
Oui, si vous voulez le pot de miel ça
existe. Donc faut voir les premières
abeilles qui arrivent qui vont se casser
les dars et puis après bah on passera
peut-être en deuxième rideau. On est
quand même en France. L'activité
d'ingérence en France, ça relève de la
DCRI. À l'extérieur, c'est la DGSE et
puis c'est la compétition entre tous les
services étrangers. Mais en France,
c'est le monopole de la DGSI, donc il y
a pas de problème. Si vous êtes une
cible, on va s'intéresser à vous, on va
vous environner pour essayer d'avoir le
résultat qui nous intéresse.
D'accord ? Donc le contreespionnage en
France,
qu'est-ce que la DCI prend comme mesure
proactive pour un protéger ses citoyens
et ensuite communiquer avec la DGSE pour
savoir qui fait de l'ingérance sur le
territoire pour contre-attaquer, avoir
une attitude beaucoup plus agressive ?
Alors d'abord
chaque pays,
vous pensez que les les services sont
suffisamment agressifs au 21e siècle ?
Non, on n' pas à être agressif comme ça
de premier à bord mais parce que il faut
d'abord regardez tous les pays ne sont
pas identiques et ne travaillent pas de
la même façon. Vous pouvez avoir des
services amis avec lesquels vous
coopérez sur la lutte antiterroriste à
40 % et à 60 % ils vous défoncent sur le
reste.
Pourquoi vous appelez ça des amis alors
? Parce que ce sont des amis avec
lesquels euh on j'appelle pas ça des
amis moi.
Ah non mais si vous voulez
les Américains là non
par exemple si vous voulez mais dans la
lutte antiterroriste, vous pensez que
tout seul on est très fort ? Vous pensez
que les renseignements techniques et
autres acquis sur des zones de combat
vous les avez en claquant du doigt ? Et
non, il faut une coopération. Cette
coopération,
elle doit être efficace, technique,
étendue dans le temps, dans la confiance
et autres. Ça représente une partie des
échanges. Laissi travaille à peu près
180 liaisons extérieures. Ça en fait du
monde. Donc vous échangez sur des
thématiques. Vous échangez surtout en
bilatéral, vous l'avez compris parce
qu'il existera jamais un service de
renseignement européen parce que ça
relève de la souveraineté de l'État et
le traité de Lisbonne le rappelle. Mais
vous êtes obligé à un moment de coopérer
sur certains domaines mais pour mieux
riposter et être en veille sur d'autres.
Et c'est là-dessus où les mêmes
personnes peuvent être amenées à vous
faire du rentre dedans, à essayer de
recruter vos agents ou certains
personnels politiques, scientifiques,
des ministères et autres. Le système de
veille de sensibilisation est un des
maîtres mots, je dirais, de l'action de
la DGSI.
Ensuite, il y a toute la partie
compromission.
Mais aujourd'hui, lorsqu'un
au fonctionnaire
d'une
de l'Assemblée du Sénat spécialisé
puisqu'il y a des des experts, des
spécialisations, certaines de monde se
fait approcher par quelqu'un relevant
d'une ambassade au niveau amical,
scientifique ou autre, il y a cette
obligation de rendre compte et ensuite
on veille à ce que le contact ne dérape
pas.
On peut rouler sur la ligne jaune
continue, on peut pas la franchir.
On veille comment ?
Mais c'est toute la mission
toute l'année de la DGSI qui accompagne
ce genre de contact.
Comment ? tout simplement
la personne contactée, vous allez être
contactée par quelqu'un, vous allez
venir rendre compte et on va vous dire
"Ben, vous allez remettre tel document
jusqu'à ce qu'on voit si vraiment il y a
une action offensive ou simplement une
action amicale de coopération ou
d'échange entre chercheurs notamment. Et
si on franchit, bah c'est du flagrant
d'lit et là on est sur de la
compromission.
Qui qui qui quelle puissance euh fait de
l'ingérence en France ? toutes.
Dites-moi,
mais toutes
les pires, les pires, qui nous dépouille
? Qui nous dépouille ?
Mais
qui nous dépouille ou qui nous castre ?
On nous teste, on est très gentil et le
domaine de la recherche est un
très ou trop
trop.
Vous savez quand on a 17000 chetchen à
l'époque qui ont demandé l'asile
politique, ça fait un peu beaucoup quand
même. Quand on sait qu'ils sont tous
dans les mir du Caucas pour aller avec
lesour, les Ozbac et autres et les
autres islamistes radicaux faire la
guerre aux Russes, je pense qu'on
pourrait les mettre ailleurs. Enfin, ça
c'est un autre sujet. Mais par exemple,
qu'est-ce que fait la DCI pour contrer
l'action des États-Unis sur notre
territoire ? Est-ce que la DCI déploie
des choses pour empêcher le dernier
étage de l'ambassade des États-Unis de
poutrer l'ensemble de Paris ?
C'est un vieux sujet mais il y a pas que
l'ambassade des États-Unis, il y a bien
a d'autres endroits.
Oui, mais c'est nos amis donc qui aiment
bien châti bien sûr. Mais c'est pas un
problème dans la mesure où le sujet
reste que le développement technologique
c'est une chose,
l'utilité qu'ils en font, l'utilisation
qu'ils en font en est une autre. Quand
la NSA écoute Angela Merkel, tout le
monde rigole parce qu'on dit mais
pourquoi et autres. Vous savez quand on
a nos ordinateurs à Bercy ou celui de
Xavier Musquet à l'Élysée à l'époque qui
est pillé, on est à 6 mois avant de
prendre la présidence européenne, il y a
peut-être un sujet intéressant à suivre.
L'action politique est un sujet qui
devient de plus en plus important et
prioritaire. Anna Chapman.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait Anna Chapman ?
Brillante, sujette.
Oui, en plus. Bah, c'est l'espionne type
quoi. La James Bond mais envoyé par nos
amis russes sur le territoire américain.
10 ans de légende, elle sera balancée
par un officier du GRU qui a défecté et
elle commence à faire de l'acquisition
de renseignement dans le domaine
politique, F tank et autres, enfin tous
ceux qui auront la décision.
Elle sera arrêtée bien sûr et puis
libérée avec les honneurs d à son rond.
Mais ça veut dire quoi ? Qu'aujourd'hui
le domaine de l'espionnage s'intéresse à
tout complètement tout. Avant, on était
plus branché sur le train avant de
l'Airbus 320,
le Concorde.
Il y a eu de belles opérations de fête
avec nos amis russes.
Après, c'est le potentiel bien sûr
scientifique, mais le militaire a été
largement dépassé, même s'il reste
toujours d'un excellent niveau.
aujourd'hui c'est la décision politique,
l'Europe par rapport à la géopolitique
que vous suivez parfaitement bien.
Chine, USA,
Israël, Turquie, les Russes, la Syrie au
milieu et on voit bien qu'il y a une
recomposition du paysage géopolitique.
Donc tout ceci, si on veut éclairer un
président de la République qui veut à
chaque fois être offensif, mais il faut
acquérir du renseignement sur
l'intention
des uns et des autres de prendre telle
ou telle décision, ce qui peut être
néfaste aux intérêts du pays qui conduit
la politique d'acquisition de
renseignement. Donc c'est un domaine qui
a largement évolué, d'où ça ne vous a
pas échappé
que les services
après avoir déployé je dirais un plan de
développement technologique
se sont mis. C'était un des vœux pieux à
l'époque quand le gouvernement Sarkozi a
est parti.
Comment ça s'appelle ce village paumé là
?
Comment il s'appelle ?
Vous le direz pas.
Si si ça fait rire.
Non mais c'est un peu le trop du cul du
monde non ? C'est ça.
Oui, bien sûr. Et donc aujourd'hui,
c'est de du recrutement.
C'est vous qui avez choisi ça ?
Pas du tout. Moi
qui c'est qui a choisi ça ?
Ah c'est pas moi. Mais c'était en
fonction du prix du mètre carré et autre
à l'époque.
C'est du foutage de gueule.
C'était la campagne.
C'était du foutage de gueule.
Mais ça c'est la partie visible. Après
il y a les 9/10è que vous ne connaissez
pas. Rassurez-vous.
Oh là là. Comment il s'appelle le
village ?
Mais vous allez le trouver sur la carte.
C'est pas très loin, c'est à 45 minutes.
Et donc si vous voulez, il y a aussi
tout le recrutement des experts, qu'il
soient scientifique mais aussi en terme
géopolitique sur des états phare. Donc
c'est là, je dirais le surplus
qualitatif qui a été ajouté, la valeur
ajoutée.
Comment ça se fait que nous on est
capable de trouver le village ?
Mais tout le monde c'est sur la carte,
c'est du mapping et tout. Oui,
vous le dites pas. Oh mais c'est bouler
les trous pour la DCRI et puis pour
Mortier, c'est d'autres choses.
Mortier mortier, on les a attrapé avec
leur monde connecté. Comment vous
expliquer que la DGSE se balade avec des
mondes connectés en OPEX ?
Ils font trop de sport.
Est-ce que la Est-ce que la DCI est
censée sensibiliser les gens de la DGSE
sur ce type de poutrage ? Non, mais
d'abord ils ont euh eux-mêmes leur
professionnalisme, ils ont eux-mêmes
leur services de sécurité surtout à
l'extérieur, mais à l'intérieur, ils
sont peut-être euh un peu plus libres
parce qu'il faut bien vivre aussi. Mais
sachez qu'il y a des échanges, des
échanges d'expérience, de coopération et
de formation avec la DGSI aujourd'hui et
avant la DCRI. Oui, ça se fait. Quant au
montre, il faut pas tout à fait vivre
avec son époque technologique. Il vaut
mieux une vieille cabine téléphonique à
pièces, mais il y en a plus.
Revenons au contreespionnage.
Euh, quel est le plus gros dossier qui
vous a passionné ces dernières années
quand vous étiez encore en poste ?
Oh euh sans trahir de secret, c'est tous
ces témoins très actifs qui ont
participé avant même la construction de
notre Pentagone à la française et qui se
sont je dirais intéressés à la
géographie de ce regroupement.
Regroupement qui était nécessaire bien
sûr, mais alors là
par Nicolas Sarkozi,
oui, mais c'était un pot de miel.
Donc ça attiré beaucoup de monde. Bah il
suffisait de regarder qui ça intéressé
puis ça nous donnait une idée de ceux
qui allaient être offensifs. Point bar.
Est-ce que Al-Qaïda fait du
renseignement de terrain ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Comment ?
Mais Al-Qaïda a récupéré savamment
les officiers supérieurs des
renseignements iraakiens en créant
l'amniat. Alors l'amniat, c'est quoi ?
Quand vous êtes djihadiste, vous arrivez
d'Europe, de France, ben on va vous
passer au tami d'abord. On va voir si
vous êtes pas un agent infiltré. Et là,
ça devient très dur.
Alors, vous allez être d'abord au corvé
de poubelle ou de cuisine et ensuite on
on va passer à la question.
Deuxièmement,
ils étaient chargés de faire les
auditions des prisonniers et donc la
torture et autres et d'acquérir
également du renseignement qui pouvait
protéger l'organisation Al-Qaïda mais
également être offensif. Enfin, et
l'affaire pont est un élément
intéressant de ce sujet. Il y avait une
occase pour infiltrer les services de
renseignement et militaires qui
faisaient partie de la coalition alliée
et il fallait les neutraliser. Donc
aujourd'hui, cette infiltration, c'est
du travail de haut niveau mais qui reste
toujours en tête de la part des gens qui
dirigent maintenant dans la
clandestinité Al-Qaïda. bien sûr, ce
soit en Irak ou ailleurs, mais qui ont
gardé présent à l'esprit, même en
l'absence de territoire national, cet
esprit défensif et offensif.
Donc, ce sont des choses dont il faut
absolument tenir compte. Il faut pas les
sous-estimer. Ce n'est pas parce qu'ils
n'ont plus de territoires et qu'ils ont
moins d'armée et autres qui ne sont pas
moins offensifs. Au contraire, la
clandestinité, les réseaux sociaux
permettent de les réactiver et
d'entretenir, je dirais, un niveau
stratégique et offensif assez
qualitatif. Comment vous expliquez qu'il
n'est pas euh saisi l'opportunité de la
crise du Covid-19 pour frapper
pour frapper une une centrale nucléaire,
pour frapper un hôpital, pour frapper
une école, pour frapper euh tout un tas
d'objectifs qui sont déjà prédéfinis.
D'abord, l'action des services est quand
même déterminante. Il y a eu après le le
Bataclan et Charlie Hebdo bien sûr
est-ce que vous
Oui, un ressaisissement des services
mais au niveau européen parce que on
avait compris que tout venait de
Belgique. La Belgique est un service
très performant, la sûreté de tabel mais
ils peuvent suivre deux objectifs, trois
objectifs maximum et d'abord ils suivent
les leurs. ils s'intéressent moins sauf
s'ils ont de la disponibilité à ceux qui
viennent frapper en France ou à
l'étranger et c'est tout à fait logique
mais il faut pas leur jeter la pierre
s'ils étaient plus nombreux ils auraient
mieux bossé et et le côté molenbeck
n'est qu'un exemple de vivier dans
lequel il faut bosser
les djihadistes ont bien compris que ce
virus ils ont saisi la balobon en disant
mais c'est une vengeance d'Allah pour
frapper les mécréants et notamment le
porteavion Charles de Gaul ou le
porte-avion amé américain. Donc ils se
sont gossés, je dirais de cette tournure
des événements et il reste toujours dans
l'actualité
aujourd'hui. Pourquoi il ne frappe pas
en France ? Parce que d'une part, il y a
une activité beaucoup plus dense des
services, y compris pendant le Covid.
D'autre part, la dissémination, je
dirais après tout ce qui se passe en
Syrie n'a pas à empêcher quand même la
reconstitution de réseaux qui pouvaient
frapper en Europe. Donc tout ce qui est
retournise et autres, les revenants.
Mais nous avons chez nous ce terrorisme
inspiré Valence et autres ou Annière
plus récemment. Donc, il faut faire
attention aux esprits un peu fragiles ou
convertis euh par voie d'internet et
autres et qui se revendiquent, je dirait
d'Al-Qaïda pour pouvoir opérer une
action symbolique, quel que soit le
moment, quel que soit résilience ou
sentinelle, puisque les forces de l'or
sont également visées confè les deux
motards qui se sont retrouvés coincés
euh savamment par euh l'automobiliste
qui était quand même bien mû au niveau
conversion et islamisme radical.
Comment vous expliquez qu'on n pas
détecté ? Vous parlez d'Anière. Comment
vous expliquez qu'on n pas détecté ?
Agnière
quelqu'un quelqu'un qui a les mains dans
toutes les bécanes de la maison.
Oui. Non mais tout à fait. Je crois que
c'est quoi ? C'est c'est un échec. C'est
c'est c'est de la feignantise. C'est
c'est quoi ? Le mec avait été signalé
quand même, non ? Oui, bien sûr, mais
aujourd'hui, mais comme vous avez euh
l'individu qui était parti euh de l'est
de la France qui était fiché à suivi,
puis vient donner des coups de couteau
euh dans des rues où les gens viennent
boire des un fonctionnaire là, payé par
l'État,
pardon,
le mec qui a tranché le
Non, là, je parlais de d'un individu, un
Tchan ou je ne sais plus, qui venait à
Paris alors qu'il était suivi à
Strasbourg et autres et qui vient, je
dirais, donner coup de couteau à des
gens qui viennent boire un coup aux
terrasses de Bistro tout à fait
normalement le vendredi soir. Bon, je
crois qu'aujourd'hui le renseignement
le souci et le souci du coordonnateur
national du renseignement c'est
justement la coordination. Les
renseignements, il y en a beaucoup. Il y
a des groupes d'évaluation
départementaux qui sont mis sous
l'autorité des préfets. Euh on a dilué
un petit peu et on a décentralisé. Mais
au niveau du suivi des individus pouvant
passer à l'axe, on n' pas évolué et on
reste toujours dans un flou artistique
puisqu'on est dans un pays de liberté.
Bon, les Américains
depuis 2001, ils travaillent sur le
patriote acte au niveau législatif, ce
qui leur permet
avant avant 2001 d'ailleurs,
bien sûr, mais ce qui leur permet
d'avoir des capacités techniques et
autres très offensives et très larges,
ce que Snowden a révélé du reste puisque
il était le formateur des formateurs de
la NSA. Donc il en savait un petit rayon
et il nous le livre euh je dirais par
paquet cadeau.
Deuxièmement, la coordination
aujourd'hui, c'est ce qui est le plus
grand souci puisque cette coordination
doit être livrée dans le détail. et le
coordonateur national du renseignement
qui est un poste créé par Nicolas
Sarkozi, amélioré par Emmanuel Macron
puisqu'il a poussé dans ses extrêmes le
fonctionnement et le rôle de ce cet
échelon suprême au niveauéen, ce qui est
une très bonne chose. Donc redonne des
directives à différents services.
Lorsqu'on a voulu réunifier le
renseignement intérieur, c'était pas
c'est pas une mode mais ça correspondait
à un besoin. Et je vais vous dire quel
était le besoin.
C'était des crémé ceux qui ne votaient
pas pour SarkoZ ?
Non. Dans la mesure où les RG avaient
déjà abandonné le côté politique depuis
un petit moment avec Charles Pasquois.
En plus cette réforme,
c'est Jacques Fournet, préfet qualifié
de gauche,
qui l'a voulu, qui a essayé de la faire
passer avec Charles Pasquais qui n'a pas
réussi avec Nicolas Sarkozi, ministre de
l'intérieur aussi puisqueà l'époque
Jacques Chirac ne l'avait pas voulu et à
un moment il y avait nécessité. Pourquoi
? 1995
la France est touchée par des attentats
sans précédents en provenance du GIA.
Auparavant, les Américains nous alertent
sur Jamel Bégal arrêté aux Émirats arabe
et qui avait l'intention,
selon les sources américaines, de
procéder à un attentat contre
l'ambassade des États-Unis, place de la
Concorde à Paris. Et de là euh
la CIA nous réunit à mortier,
renseignements généraux, direction de la
surveillance du territoire et des GSE.
Et là, on s'aperçoit que chaque service
français a un morceau du puzzle et que
personne ne s'est coordonné et que ce
sont les Américains qui nous coordonnent
sur le territoire national. Donc ça fait
un peu je dirais désordre. De là est né
un petit peu le souci de recoordonner
les services intérieurs dans la mesure
où la menace avait largement évolué.
La menace interne et la menace interne
n'existait plus en terme de différence.
Tout provenait de zones tribales que ce
soit la DRM, la DCRI, la DST du
renseignement militaire, je expliquer ce
qu'il y a
ou la DGSE, tout le monde travaillait
sur les mêmes qui allaient nous former
des gens qui allaient venir frapper
notre territoire national ou nos
intérêts français à l'étranger, un avion
Air France sur un aéroport ou une
ambassade. Donc c'est de là qu' né le
souci de coordonner au moins le
renseignement intérieur dans la mesure
où il y avait deux domaines. toute la
lutte antiterroriste
au niveau renseignements généraux, le
côté politique, social, économique,
financier, course et jeux et donc il a
fallu un petit peu démanteler tout ça.
On a récupéré la DST et Joël Bouffité,
le directeur central des RG partant,
nous a laissé tout le bloc terro avec
tous les dossiers et les personnels qui
allaient avec. Donc il n'y a eu aucune
perte contrairement à ce que j'entends
et ceux qui critiquent cette
cette réforme sont ceux qui ont demander
la suppression des arg. Je ne dirai pas
de nom mais j'ai tout en
si on donne des noms là.
Ah ben monsieur Baou, le parti
socialiste et autres. Et quand je vois
que la DCRI a été critiquée, Emmanuel
Vas n'a fait que la renforcer par une la
création d'une direction générale qui la
rend autonome au niveau budgétaire, mais
la coupe de ses bases territoriales par
rapport aux autres services de police,
ce qui était une erreur puisqu'on y
avait pensé, on l'avait pas fait
volontairement. Donc aujourd'hui, un
seul service de renseignement intérieur,
une DGSE.
Je vous coupe, je vous coupe. Parlez-moi
plus du renseignement territorial.
Pourquoi c'est si important ? Mais le
renseignement territorial est très
important. Mais la réforme a pris du
retard avec la direction centrale de la
sécurité publique au début qui n'a pas
compris tout l'intérêt qu'il y avait à
performer là-dessus. On a perdu 3 ans.
Il a fallu attendre l'arrivée de Jacques
Fournier, un copain de promotion pour
pouvoir échanger et rattraper le retard
parce que la DCRI pendant les travaux,
la réforme, elle continuait à arrêter
les gens, démanteler des réseaux, faire
son boulot, coopérer au niveau
international et la DCSP par contre a eu
du retard à l'allumage. Aujourd'hui,
c'est un service performant le
renseignement territorial. Euh les
choses ont été prises en compte, la
gendarmerie a été intégrée et
aujourd'hui il faut capter euh je dirais
ce que faisaient les RG dans les
quartiers sensibles, côté banlieu et
autres, le côté euh également
analyse, contact, économie souterraine,
tout ce qui était communément appelé les
signaux faibles. Aujourd'hui,
la communauté française du renseignement
prend en compte tout ce qui arrive de
ces filtres en premier rideau et traite
pour neutraliser ce qui risque d'être un
sujet nuisible pour notre territoire
national.
Comment vous exp
Mais ça a mis du temps.
Comment vous expliquez que quelqu'un qui
travaille à la DCI arrive à faire un
attentat dans les locaux de la DCI ?
C'est les RGPP, pardon.
Pardon, excusez-moi. Comment vous
expliquez ça ? La RGPP.
Alors, lorsque
j'étais à la tête de la DCRI qu'on a
créé cette réforme, j'ai demandé à ce
que le bloc terro terrorisme de RGPP
soit avalé par la DCIRI à charge pour
moi de mettre
un commissaire divisionnaire en tant
qu'agent de liaison auprès du préfet de
police pour qu'il soit parfumé entre
guillemets informé de tout ce qui se
passait sur la capitale parisienne. et
également
tout ce qui pouvait arriver au niveau
coopération internationale et concerné
Paris.
Pour des raisons qui me dépassent, ça
n'a pas été accepté. J'ai témoigné
devant une commission d'enquête
parlementaire récemment pour expliquer
tout ceci en explique en disant qu'on
avait eu du retard, que c'était dommage
parce que c'est un service performant
mais qu'il fallait coordonner et
centraliser parce que le renseignement
ça doit passer sous des fourches codines
pour être évalué. Il faut lever le
doute, faut le confirmer et ensuite faut
l'enrichir et
informer qui de droit.
Donc aujourd'hui, il y avait encore ce
trou dans la raquette. Je ne sais pas
quelle sera la décision de la commission
d'enquête, mais à mon sens, tout ce bloc
doit être transféré sous une seule main,
celle de Nicolas Lerner, l'actuel
Partron de la DGSI, avec bien sûr mise
en place de structures de liaison, sinon
on aura des problèmes de coordination.
Comment se fait-il que les frères Kashi
ne soient pas suivis à Reins alors
qu'ils étaient pris en compte à Paris ?
C'est tout le problème ou l'histoire du
prêtre assassiné en Normandie là aussi
gros problème.
Alors quel est le véritable problème de
tout ça ? Est-ce qu'un préfet de police
de Paris parce qu'il y en a qu'un,
monsieur monsieur comment il s'appelle ?
Ah non, mais là c'est monsieur
l'allemand mais peu importe, c'est la
fonction est plus important qu'un
directeur général de la police nationale
qui rencontre au même ministre
ou alors tout le monde est à égalité et
c'est là où ça se joue. Donc il faudra
qu'un jour l'État tranche ce problème de
protocole.
Un préfet de police à Paris, ça a
d'énormes pouvoirs bien sûr, mais
aujourd'hui euh madame Galgo souhaite
créer une police municipale, donc couper
la partie budgétaire qui allait à la
préfecture de police pour la consacrer à
sa vraie police municipale de terrain.
Mais avec quel pouvoir ? C'est là où ça
doit se jouer. Bon, circulation et tout.
Mais aujourd'hui, le préfet de police ne
va pas demander si madame Hidalgo est
d'accord pour bloquer une rue, si tel
ministre ou tel président étranger vient
dans Paris et on doit bloquer telle voie
à la circulation pour tel ou tel
problème. Donc voilà, ça se situe là.
Mais aujourd'hui,
l'évolution de la préfecture de police
est à trancher avec le côté évolution de
la métropole, des grandes structures
parisiennes. Il va falloir reposer tout
le problème et donc tous les pouvoirs
qui vont avec. Mais dans le même ordre
d'idée, le 36 qui est des orfœuvres, qui
a donc euh évolué euh dans le 17e,
est également soumis au même problème en
disant "Mais pourquoi la direction
centrale de la police judiciaire
n'aspirerait pas euh le 36 qui est des
ordres comme grande structure régionale
avec le SRP, la DIPI, je Versailles et
autres dans son sein ?
C'est le ministère contre la préfecture
de police. Et là, l'arbitre, il se situe
à un autre niveau, c'està-dire vous
traversez la rue et vous trouvez la
décision. Comment vous expliquez que les
services turcs préviennent les services
français,
que certains individus cherchent à faire
des des attentats sur le territoire et
que personne ne réagit correctement et
qu'on se retrouve avec des petits
problèmes sur la problème sur la
promenade des Anglais.
Oui. Alors, les renseignements en
provenance du territoire national des
différents services plus des services
étrangers,
c'est une espèce de douche. Donc c'est
là où il faut trier, centraliser,
prendre en compte, lever le doute et
suivre. Après suivre les gens, si
vraiment c'est un objectif opérationnel
digne de ce nom, ça demande du monde et
là il faut faire des choix. Alors, c'est
là où les choix doivent être faits avec
un soutien politique. En Angleterre,
toutes les semaines, le Homeland
sécurité se réunit entre les services,
tout service confondus et le politique
décide la grille et les échelons de
priorité qui sont proposés par les
services. Ça veut dire que si ensuite il
y a un problème, le politique soutient
le technique.
Ensuite,
bien sûr,
mais le renseignement est apprécié
différemment.
Outre manche, on n'est pas dans la même
culture.
C'est ça la différence. Vous disiez
c'est un boulot de barbouse. Non,
non, j'ai pas dit que c un bou de
barbou. Je vous ai posé une question.
Est-ce que les renseignements c'est un
métier de voyou fait par des seigneurs
ou est-ce que le renseignement est un
métier de truc de de de roi fait par des
truants ? C'est un métier de
professionnel.
Non mais des professionnels a des
professionnels tr mais mais vous mais
vous allez au confessionnel de la
Madeleine, vous cherchez vos tuyaux ou
vous allez en Égypte, vous parcourez le
monde et
bien renseigné vous hein ?
Et oui parce qu'on vous a suivi avec
votre montre électrique électronique.
Non j'ai pas de montre ça tombe bien.
Non mais le renseignement il se fait
comment ? à travers une analyse, vous
allez cibler un noyau. Le noyau, il est
dans le monde dans lequel il évolue,
dans l'écosystème. À partir de là, vous
essayez de trouver une source humaine,
de la source technique, des
surveillances opérationnelles. Vous
amenez la preuve de ce que vous avancez
en terme d'analyse par des supports
opérationnels. Parce que tout ceci c'est
destiné à quoi ? Si c'est une analyse
sur le contre espionnage, c'est pas un
problème. Mais si c'est pour neutraliser
un individu, faut amener la charge de la
preuve devant une juridiction. Je vous
rappelle que et qui a une intime
conviction et je vous rappelle que la
DGSI a aussi est aussi un service de
police judiciaire. Elle fait du
renseignement mais elle fait aussi du
judiciaire.
Donc si j'ai pris à l'époque Frédéric
Vau l'actuel DGPN directeur général de
la police nationale c'est qu'il était
numéro 2 de la direction centrale de la
poliche judiciaire pour savoir à quel
moment on pouvait judiciariser le
renseignement. Donc je prenais le must
qui était le numéro 2 de la police
judiciaire pour pas qu'on m'accuse parce
qu'on a toujours été accusé de vouloir
garder le renseignement pour soi et de
ne pas le judiciariser. Je m'explique.
Dans la lutte antie
travailler avec les services espagnols
que ce soit le CNI espagnol, la DGSE, la
guardia civile, la commissariat général
d'information, la police, la police
autonome basque, l'erchinza et donc nous
avions des éléments et tout. Mais le
choix se posait en ces termes.
Nous avions identifié par exemple, c'est
un exemple, tel agent de liaison
français qui amenait les petites
informations à tel Étatara chef de tel
appareil planqué en France pour qu'il
lui redonne des instructions pour que
des commandos aillent frapper en Espagne
des casernes de Groire civil et faire
les 800 morts qu'ils ont eu au bout de
leur activité.
La PJ nous disait on arrête tel agent de
liaison et nous on disait non il va nous
amener à tel responsable et à tel cache.
Et c'est là où se situe le discernement
et l'intérêt avec bien sûr le côté
judiciaire lorsque tous les
renseignements sont judiciarisés.
L'intérêt de travailler tous ensemble.
Est-ce qu'il vaut mieux arrêter un petit
maillon ou arriver au bout de la chaîne
?
C'est là où ça se situe. Donc
aujourd'hui
et à travers certaines affaires, le
renseignement est de plus en plus
judiciarisé par précaution et notamment
après Charlie Hebdo et le Bataclan pour
en revenir à votre question. Et donc si
vous voulez au lieu de couper la pelouse
tous les 15 jours, ben on essaie de la
couper tous les jours même si l'herbe
n'est pas très haute. Donc c'est ça
aujourd'hui il faut judiciariser à
outrance. quand vous étiez encore en
action euh les services turcs
opérationnel pas opérationnel
très opérationnel
excellemment opérationnel en plus sur la
Syrie, ils ont apporté beaucoup et
lorsque monsieur Caz a dit "Mais nous
contrôlerons tous les flux migratoires
qui arriveront par la Grèce, problème
c'est que les gens qui ont fait le
batacloriote se sont ils sont arrivés
par la Grèce. Donc je ne sais pas
comment on a bien contrôlé. Mais tout ce
qui vient de Turquie, on le voit
aujourd'hui le chantage, si voilà, on
vous renvoie tous les migrants en
Europe.
Millions, deux petits millions tr petits
millions.
Oui, bien sûr. Et de façon clandestine,
bien sûr. Mais aujourd'hui, la Turquie,
bon
s'est posé la question savoir si elle
allait intégrer l'Europe ou non. Mais il
est évident que c'est sur le plateau de
la balance, ça fait remonter l'autre
plateau.
Préférez manger avec Poutine ou Erdogan
?
Poutine.
Pourquoi ?
J'aime bien ces services.
Lesquels ?
FSB
ou Gru ?
GRU, c'est autre chose. SVR, moi j'aime
bien le FSB parce que on a travaillé
ensemble sur de belles opérations. Ils
nous ont aidé. On les a aidé.
Lesquel ? Lesquels ?
Les TCchen qui étaient en France et qui
ont commis des tentatives d'attentat
contre le métro de Moscou. Et on a pu
euh leur expliquer qu'on travaillait
là-dessus.
des gens aussi bons que le 17e RDP,
le 13e RDP côté français euh
amener les gens qui avaient fait la
revendication depuis une certaine ville
en pas très loin de Paris, des gens qui
étaient dans la Sart et ils ont apprécié
et on a même pu
faire venir des magistrats en commission
orgatoire internationale et ils ont
apprécié, ils se pensaient pas qu'on
puisse travailler sur ces ces islamistes
qui étaient un peu les leurs.
Bon, bien sûr, ils nous ont demandé une
aide lorsqu'ils ont organisé toutes leur
compétition sportive de haut niveau, on
l'a fait. Après, bien sûr qu'ils aient
une action aussi comme d'autres pays
amis, bien sûr, mais on le sait.
Comment vous expliquez que on trouve des
nids de russes
dans la montagne avec des des des
maisons qui servent de points ? relais
pour aller par exemple en Suisse ou
aller en Italie
sur le territoire français. Vous l'avez
la dessérie était au courant depuis des
années et elle a sorti ça de sa poche
comme un comme un petit trophée qu'on
offre à son président chasseur pour
qu'il puisse faire une petite
déclaration avant la présid l'avenue de
Poutine.
Est-ce que les services se comportent
pas un petit peu comme
le le chien savant, le chien de cirque
qui qui aime bien faire un petit tour
pour faire plaisir à son maître ? Alors,
vous savez les services sont
imminemment politiques.
Non, c'est pas ça. Pas du tout.
Il y a pas de police politique en France
?
Absolument pas.
Que le directeur,
regardez-moi, regardez-moi dans les yeux
et redites-moi ça.
Il y en a eu avant. Oui, bien sûr.
Avant qui ? Avant vous ou après vous ?
Oui. Non, mais avant dans la grande
époque et tout. Bon après si vous voulez
l'alternance en 1981 a commencé à casser
je dirais tout ce qui était immuable
acquis la routine les truant les machins
et 81 vent de pureté au renseignements
généraux titre le monde sous la plume de
Paul Rou patron du syndicat des
commissaires et qui devient directeur
central des RG ça veut dire que même
dans les enquêtes d'habilitation tout le
monde passait
après il y a eu une reprise en main
parce qu'on a découvert ce qu'était la
notion de sûreté de sécurité nationale
et tout ce qui pouvait porter atteinte
aux institutions. Et la loi d'amnistie
et la suppression de la Cour de sûreté
de l'État, si on on va plus au bout à
marquer la fin d'un ancien système un
peu trop militarisé,
a laissé penser qu'on allait aller euh
vers une époque où tout le monde était
gentil et autres. Et puis on a vite
compris que il fallait reprendre le
boulot et réarrêter les mêmes personnes
qu'on avait libéré. Bon mais ça c'est la
vie.
L'amnistie c'est votée par l'Assemblée
nationale. C'est la souveraineté
nationale qui décide.
Les services sont respectueux et
légitimistes. Ils exécutent. Mais c'est
certain que lorsque vous arrêtez la même
personne deux fois, trois fois, le mec
commence à connaître vos méthodes et
donc ça devient de plus en plus dur.
C'est là les limites de notre système.
Mais aujourd'hui,
pour revenir à votre question, que le
service fasse remonter ces informes.
Non, c'est bon.
Que le service fasse remonter ses
informations sur tel ou tel domaine, que
le pouvoir l'utilise à des fins autres.
Et moi, c'est très simple, je ne tonnais
pas tout et je gardais pour moi la
partie qu'il ne fallait pas donner.
Sinon, ça allait démontrer le niveau
d'acquisition auquel on était parvenu et
ça permettait à l'adversaire lorsque le
l'officiel allait redescendre avec ses
résultats de savoir où il avait été
plombé.
Revenons à C'est c'est revenons revenons
au carus dans la montagne.
Oui. Poutine doit venir en France et
genre 2 3 jours avant, comme par hasard,
on découvre un espion russe en France.
C'est quoi ? C'est c'est on on offre une
un as de trèfle
à notre président. Je parle pas d'un as
de pic.
On offre un on offre un as de trèfle à
notre président pour jouer
géopolitiquement parlant.
Alors là, c'est
est-ce que les services sont remuer de
la queue devant Macron pour lui offrir
la le
Alors, écoutez, je crois qu'il faudra
inviter Nicolas Lerner puisque c'est lui
et Bernard Émier, le patron de la DGSE.
Mais si vous voulez, sans être
sans avoir participé à ce genre de
réunion, je vois bien l'intérêt qu'il y
avait de montrer à Poutine, "Je sais ce
que tu fais chez nous, tu es un ami,
mais à côté, je dirais tu restes
offensif."
Et les services sont donné au président
qui est la première autorité de l'État,
ce qui leur était demandé tout
simplement.
parce que on a une petite caméra qui
saute mais c'est bon. Vous faites le
point sur le le large gars. Merci.
Donc aujourd'hui un service ça ramène du
renseignement, ça le travaille, ça
l'enrichit, ça le stocke. Et un jour on
vous appelle en disant qu'est-ce que
vous avez en bibliothèque sur tel sujet
? Mais vous ne savez pas pourquoi. Ce
n'est qu'après que vous comprenez que
comment ça a été utilisé, comment dans
des échanges à un niveau international.
C'est l'affaire Farwell.
C'est l'affaire Colona.
Non, l'affaire Colona rien à voir. Mais
l'affaire, est-ce qu'on a offert Est-ce
qu'on a offert à Sarkozi Colona pour
qu'il
Absolument pas pour Alors là si vous
voulez bon Yvan Colona était quelqu'un
qui devait se présenter à la justice.
Bon, il a pris la fuite. Des moyens ont
été mis en place pour qu'il défaire je
dirais à l'instruction qu'il à laquelle
il devait passer. Ensuite, c'est la
justice qui est passée. Mais l'affaire
Farwell pour être encore plus
alors Farwell qui était un agent sous
traité par les Français qui avait les
clés du coffre du KGB et je vous laisse
terminer.
Alors, c'est quelqu'un qui était dans
une certaine ligne. Tout ce qui est
l'acquisition au sein du KGB de la ligne
scientifique
pure.
Oui. Oui, bien sûr. Donc, tout ce qui
était recherche par les nos amis
soviétiques à les grandes époques,
guerre froide du pillage de données qui
était sur le territoire national. Donc
par savant mélange,
Raymond Nart, le grand sous-directeur
chargé du contreespionnage à la DST, a
pu travailler intelligemment grâce à des
liaisons, l'intéresser, se faire
remettre des documents qui nous ont
enrichis. C'est une époque un peu
difficile pour François Mitteran qui a
pris quatre ministres communistes dans
son gouvernement et qui donc se voit la
porte américaine fermée mais de façon
blindée. Et donc
ça a été une monnaie d'échange pour
montrer aux Américains
la vassalisation de la France.
Voilà. Et le fait que on savait
distinguer
l'important le principal de
l'accessoire. Ça a tué un homme.
Vladimir Vetrof est mort.
Alors pourquoi les services ont toujours
répugne à donner les résultats de leur
investigation aux politiques ? Parce
qu'un politique ça ne fait que passer.
Le service y reste et tient à ses
sources. C'est pas le directeur, le
directeur il fait que passer. Mais toute
l'infrastructure de confiance que vous
avez mise en place pour gérer des
sources humaines, c'est une relation de
confiance qui s'établit avec euh je
dirais le la source, traitant, tout ce
qui remonte et tout et on veut protéger
ça. Et du jour au lendemain,
il arrive ce que l'on pressentait et
c'est pour ça qu'on a toujours plus
d'heur à donner
intégralement le résultat de nos
recherches. qu'on essaie de le faire de
façon démarquée pour éviter qu'on
neidentifie
toute l'origine et bien sûr le niveau
auquel est placé la source. Donc
si je dois lire entre les lignes, les
politiques sont des Benets, crament vos
sources et vous font passer pour des
cons.
Bah Poutine est un ancien des renseignes
du renseignement donc lui il a
conscience de tout ça. Nos présidents,
bon ils ont plein d'autres qualités mais
pas celle-ci et leur entourage non plus.
C'est là où la protection des sources
reprend tout le dessus. Soit vous faites
du renseignement et vous grillez vos
sources en 3 secondes, soit vous
l'installez dans la durée, vous la
faites monter dans les organigrammes et
vous avez des choses de grande qualité.
Vous
êtes
Nous, on préfère la deuxième solution.
Vous êtes un homme libre.
Oh oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'administration Macron ? Ah non, mais
euh l'administration Macron, si vous
voulez, euh le le Covid révèle que on
revient sur le couple préfémèire.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'un système trop
centralisateur,
c'est néfaste. Vous allez pas ouvrir la
plage euh d'Ilrousse ou de Calvie de la
même façon que celle du Trésir ou de
Plougonvelin à Brest. ça a rien à voir
ou à Saint-Trope ou à Jacio.
Aujourd'hui, il faut compter avec de la
décentralisation, de la proximité, du
bon sens paysan qu'on pas du
discernement. Et c'est là tout le sujet.
Quand il y a eu la critique sur le
confinement, le traitement des banlieux
avec discernement, j'ai fait une vidéo
avec Booba,
personnage que je ne connaissais pas,
qui n'a pas l'air d'aimer la police.
Comment il vous a contacté ?
Par des intermédiaires puisqu'on a aussi
des intermédiaires corse ou
non ? Pas du tout, normaux,
continentaux, vous voyez. Donc il y a
pas que la mafia curse,
pas des pintou, c'est ça ? Non, pas des
sout et puis en plus, bon le rap c'est
pas trop mon truc. Bon, il aimait pas la
police. Donc pourquoi ? C'est un vecteur
très important parce que lui au moins,
il est écouté comme le journal officiel
par toutes les autorités sur le
territoire national.
Le fait d'expliquer
que le confinement c'était important,
lui seul pouvait faire passer le
message, je m'y suis prêté volontiers,
même si c'était pas mon boulot, mais je
l'ai fait pour aider à la manœuvre
l'action du ministère de l'intérieur,
calmer les banlieux et autres. Et je lui
ai fait dire "Vive la police".
Il faut pas oublier que la police est là
aussi pour aider la protection des
personnels soignants la nuit dans quand
il rentre chez eux dans des stations de
métro, il y a des junkies qui veulent
récupérer un peu de fric et tout. Voilà,
c'était tout ça. Et pour montrer que
décentralisation,
je pense que à un moment où le
département dans un cadre européen qui a
très mal fonctionné joué sa vie, je
crois que aujourd'hui le département
cher à Napoléon, le chef que de
préfecture et la journée à cheval,
reprend toutes ces lettres de noblesse.
Pourquoi tout concentrer à Paris et on
le voit bien les Parisiens qui au moment
du confinement ont préféré partir à la
campagne. C'était déjà la première
première approche. Mais aujourd'hui, le
département a un rôle à jouer. Le préfet
de département c'est une notion
essentielle. Les élus aussi. Pourquoi il
faut atter pour le premier tour qui
s'est réalisé la nomination des maires ?
parce que ce sont des points très
importants pour réaliser et décliner
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises
par le ministère de l'intérieur. C'est
c'est primordial. Donc aujourd'hui
l'administration bah elle est faite avec
je dirais toutes les structures qui
existaient auparavant mais un préfet on
leur demande beaucoup de choses à au
préfet réduire le chômage développement
économique la sécurité et bon et
aujourd'hui la pandémie. Donc c'est
c'est l'homme à tout faire de la
République quand on dit publiquement.
Mais ce sont des gens sérieux sur
lesquels on peut s'appuyer.
On parle de qui là ? Des préfets.
Les préfets, bien sûr. C'est
l'organisation gouvernementale.
La question l'administration Macron,
vous lui faites confiance pour gérer la
crise du Covid-19 ou pas ?
Bah si vous voulez à titre personnel,
bon moi je suis préfet hors cadre en
disponibilité donc je peux revenir dans
la fonction publique. C'est évident.
Dire voulez pas vous cramer
comment ? Non mais c'est pas ça, mais je
vais être très clair. Il y a eu des
problèmes de communication. Premier
point, une confusion certaine et une
précipitation.
Deuxièmement, euh
quand vous dites problème de
communication, vous appelez ça des
mensonges,
des ratés. Je crois que
alors que bon, le conseil scientifique a
été, je dirais l'aide technique qui a
permis de faire passer la pilule. Mais
sur ce virus, on en sait toujours pas
plus.
Donc on adopte des procédés moyen-âgeux,
confinement, masque bou, gel et autres
test et autres.
que l'on a assisté
aux balles des momies, des gens qui ont
jamais rien dit et ou dit je dirais des
contradictions. Oui. Maintenant le
président a géré sa crise seul,
peut-être pas très bien entouré aussi,
faut voir ou mauvais conseiller.
Aujourd'hui, on essaie d'en sortir des
confinements. On parle de d'irritation
entre le président et le premier
ministre. Le premier ministre a fait le
job et on se repose sur des échelons, je
dirais normaux. Mais pour revenir à la
discussion de départ, il y a eu une
sous-estimation du problème par manque
de renseignement. C'est évident.
Si l'OMS avait diligenté une enquête
digne de ce nom et avait fait
redescendre en pluie fine l'exactitude
si tant était possible en Chine
d'acquérir du renseignement là-dessus,
on aurait pu se préparer, je dirais un
peu mieux. Là, on a géré l'approche du
virage, je dirais, avec des des des
embardés, mais on est passé. Toujours
est-il que ça repose tout le problème du
recentrage souverainiste. Pourquoi on n
pas de masque ? Pourquoi on fabrique pas
en France ? Deuxièmement, l'échelon de
décision, il faut descendre au plus bas
niveau, la proximité parce
qu'aujourd'hui est né un sentiment de
peur.
Ça va m'en entretenu
on connaît pas. Deuxièmement, cette
peur, elle va jusqu'aux enfants et
puisqu'on parle Kawasaki, le syndrome et
tout le monde peut être touché. Mais le
virus, on ne le connaît pas. Quelqu'un
qui vient vous faire des attentats, on
le situe, on l'encadre, on l'environne.
On sait à peu près comment, qui,
pourquoi et autres. Là, c'est
impalpable. Donc cette peur, elle a été
entretenue
par la force des choses parce que la
santé c'est un sujet prioritaire et
c'est là où on s'aperçoit qu'on a
peut-être pas tout mis le paquet sur les
hôpitaux, le personnel médical et
aujourd'hui
revient à nouveau l'idée d'un nouvel
hôpital. C'est c'est quand même une
volonté forte. Après avoir récompensé
les gens, les premiers de Cordé ou de
Corvé, comme on veut, pour s'apercevoir
que pour faire vivre une nation, pour
assurer la survie d'une société, on a
besoin de petites mains et des
professionnels de l'urgence, chose que
l'on avait peut-être oublié.
Mais aujourd'hui, ne pas avoir de masque
fabriqué en France, là se situe la vraie
question et bien d'autres par la suite.
Donc il y a une espèce de remise en
condition. Également Castaner, le
ministre de l'intérieur a dû intervenir
pour expliquer qu'on avait fait des
erreurs quand un préfet de région dans
l'est de la France réquisitionne des
masques achetés par un conseil régional.
On aurait peut-être pu s'entendre avant
puisqu'on est dans un souci
d'anticipation.
Donc aujourd'hui, on apprend et on
avance en marchant mais c'est vrai que
ça va laisser des traces et on assiste à
quoi ?
Début des commissions d'enquête
parlementaire après les auditions. 63
plaines devant la cour de justice et
autres contre personnes nommément
désignées nommément des des ministres.
Donc tout ceci va laisser des traces. On
se retrouve dans l'atmosphère semblable
au sang contaminé que l'on a connu qui
est un mauvais souvenir
mais ça reprend un petit peu les mêmes
formes.
Euh
vous parlez d'hôpital, on on salue euh
certains membres de notre communauté qui
sont actuellement hospitalisés et qui
nous ont envoyé des messages. Donc on
leur passe le bonjour et on reçoite
plein plein de courage.
Mais ce sont des gens qui sont qui font
preuve d'une abdégation totale hein et
aussi
c'est énorme. Euh euh on va revenir au
sujet du contre-espionnage. J'aimerais
qu'on parle euh
de la Libye.
Vous connaissez la Libye un peu ? J'y
suis allé. Oui, je suis allé voir à
plusieurs reprises avec mes équipes
Mousakousa,
directeur du renseignement libyen que
j'ai connu bien sûr, euh avec qui euh on
a coopéré comme avec euh Ali Mamlou, le
patron des services syriens qui est qui
a un rôle très important et qui nous a
aidé sur certains sujets.
Ce sont des gens avec qui on a pu
travailler qui nous ont aidé aussi à
résoudre de par leur contact fait pas de
dessin des col case. Croyez que la rue
des rosiers ça arrive comme ça sur le
sur le tarmac
la rue des rosier rappelez-moi c'est
c'est la voiture qui était arrêtée avec
des warnings avec des bouteilles de gaz
à l'intérieur. C'est ça non ?
C'est ça.
On remonte à combien d'années en arrière
? Ben voilà. Ça veut dire que les
ennemis d'hier
peuvent être les amis d'aujourd'hui
parce que c'est politique tout ça, mais
on apprend avec eux. sont des
organisations,
comment dirais-je, qui ont aidé pas mal
de mouvement révolutionnair, terroriste
ou autres, sauf les Corses. Tiens, il
m'a dit "Tu corse et ben je peux te dire
que ceux qui ont refusé, le seul notre
aide c'est les Corses." Benah je dis
"Oui, mais on est indépendant jusqu'au
bout de des ongles." Et c'était normal.
Voilà, ça c'était pour refermer la
parenthèse mais je trouvais ça fabuleux.
Vous parlez Corse.
Comment
vous parlez Corse ? Bien sûr, et je l'ai
appris parce que lorsque on rentrait du
Maroc l'été, euh mon père qui était dans
la police chérifienne à l'époque du
protectorat du Maroc euh n'avait droit
qu'aux vacances bonifiées tous les 2
ans. Donc nous, on partait avec mon
grand frère 4 ans de plus qui a choisi
lui la direction d'administration
pénitentiaire
euh encore chez les grands-parents et
les tantes. Et là, mon grand-père qui
avait fait la guerre 141,
gazé, blessé,
fait prisonnier à Dieu sans son tras
mairie rangiment d'infanterie,
ne parlait que le corse. Et donc, il
fallait bien s'adapter. J'ai appris sur
le tas dès mon plus jeune âge avec mon
frère le dialecte, ce qui m'a servi bien
sûr et ce qui me sert en Corse en Corse
en Corse français ou vous êtes Corse ?
Je suis français
mais j'adore la Corse.
Napoléon était-il français ou Corse ?
Corse.
Mais non, les Corses sont des Italiens
au départ, ce sont des génois.
Des génois. Merci.
Et oui, mais il faut remonter aux
sources. Faut faut appeler un chat un
chat. Faut être traçable. Bien sûr qu'on
a tous une culture corse qui permet
comme l'Auvernia, le breton et et autres
de s'identifier. Mais si vous voulez, si
j'ai choisi et mon grand-père a fait la
guerre, mon père a également fait 5 ans
de guerre dans la 9e DIC, régiment
d'artie coloniale marocaine tiré à
cheval, débarquement 5 ans de guerre, ça
se ça s'oublie pas. Donc il nous
racontait ce qu'il a vécu. Donc ça vous
incule quelques principes honneur et
patrie,
le drapeau français. Donc moi ma façon,
ben voilà, j'ai choisi d'épouser
cette profession et je ne le regrette
pas, mais ça m'a permis également de
défendre nos valeurs et nos intérêts.
Donc le contre-espionnage, oui, c'est
une des facettes, je dirais, en Libye,
en Syrie et la lutte antiterroriste qui
nous a permis d'avancer.
On va revenir sur la Corse un peu plus
tard. Comment vous expliquez que dans
les années 80 90 on est diabolisé autant
les hackurs en France contrairement à ce
qu'a fait l'Allemagne ?
Ah, on a bien diabolisé les radios
libres avant 80 donc tout ceci était
nouveau. C'était un sentiment de liberté
d'un
Pouette. Oui, mais oui, mais écoutez,
c'est il faut vivre avec son temps. Euh
c'est le domaine de la liberté, des
réseaux sociaux, de l'indépendance et du
non contrôle. Bah aujourd'hui, les
Américains ont rattrapé tout ça et tout
est sous contrôle, vous l'avez bien
compris.
Ou essaie,
ils essaient de mettre tout sous
contrôle, d'où la 5G et autres.
La vie privée en France, elle se porte
comment ? Très bien.
Se porte
très bien. Lorsqu'on n'est pas nuuisible
vis-à-vis de la République, aucun
problème.
C'est pas vous qui allez dire le
contraire. Vous en vivez
la vie privée
bien sûr des libertés.
Non mais aujourd'hui on le voit chaque
problème soulève un débat téléphonique
et tout ça.
Ex tout a été régularisé je dirais
après c'est ça
non ? postériorie
bien sûr. Mais
comment ça se fait qu'en France on
utilise certaines techniques qu'on fait
légaliser qu'après
parce qu'on est dans une culture qui
n'est pas prête à accepter tout ça.
Regardez aujourd'hui le tracing
qui repose sur le volontariat et le
Bluetooth qui est lui-même très
aléatoire. Une technique qui marche dans
la Creuse le Cantal en Corse OK mais à
Paris je doute l'Autriche il y a à peu
près 5 % des utilisateurs qui ont
accepté la technique. Il y a une culture
différente au niveau européen. Or c'est
pour un bien sanitaire, c'est pour la
santé des gens. Donc on voit qu'on n'est
pas prêt
ou qu'on est tout simplement français.
Oui. Ou qu'on est tout simplement
français. Parce que bon, dès qu'il y a
un texte qui sort, on essaie de trouver
la parade pour contourner et tout.
Regardez le système des
a raison de temps en temps, non ?
Oui, mais bien sûr. Mais c'est un jeu.
Ma grand-mère Ma-mère m'a toujours dit
"Méfie-toi de ceux qui remplissent des
fiches."
Tu es pas faux.
Mais alors avant, les fiches étaient
manuelles, aujourd'hui elles sont
informatisées. C'est pire.
On été automatisé très vite, hein. C'est
pire parce que vous pouvez pas empêcher
le croisement de certains fichiers à un
certain moment. Fichier manuel, c'était
peut-être mieux.
Ouais, c'était artisanal, c'était fait
avec amour. C'est ça. On connaissait son
avec passion.
La 5G, c'est de l'industriel, c'est du
ramassage La 5G, c'est de l'industriel,
c'est du ramassage scolaire.
Regardez que fait la NSA. Elle ramasse
les métadonnées à outrance, les stock
les nôtres avec d'ailleurs.
Oui. Ah bah évidemment,
les vôtres aussi. Non.
Comment
les vôtres aussi ? Ah,
ça fait partie du système.
On a cherché. Est-ce qu'une puissance
étrangère a essayé de de vous faire
chanter ?
Non, parce qu'il y avait aucune
vulnérabilité. Par contre, quand je
passe avec mon passeport dans un pays
étranger, je reste un peu plus longtemps
que les autres parce que ça clignote en
rouge. C'est le seul problème. Mais bon,
je
Pourquoi vous êtes en rouge en ce moment
? ou parce que vous
Ah non non mais parce que j'ai exercé
une fonction qui est connue et donc
ils l'ont emmagasiné et donc si je viens
sur le territoire c'est forcément pour
aller rencontrer des contacts. Je peux y
aller à titre de tourisme.
La 5G c'est du ramassage scolaire
c'est du chalutage
bien sûr. Vous savez dans la vie soit on
pêche au harpon soit au chalu et là on
est dans le chalu industriel.
Et pourquoi la les Américains sont pas
contents ? Parce qu'ils ont pas acquis
le degré et ils veulent être les
premiers. Et on voit bien la rivalité
Chine USA en ce moment. Il y a pas que
la 5G, il y a bien d'autres choses.
Quand vous voyez que le vaccin, bon
d'abord Trump dit
"C'est la Chine qui nous a balancé
le virus."
Les Chinois disent "Ah non, ce sont les
athlètes américains qui lorsqu'ils sont
venus en compétition avec la CIA nous
ont donné le vaccin."
Virus,
le virus pardon, le le virus. Et là
aujourd'hui, les Chinois Trump dit font
du hacking pour savoir quel est le
niveau de recherche dans le domaine du
vaccin. Bon, on va pas s'arrêter là. Les
Chinois disent "On va arrêter le dollar
dans nos transactions." On s'enfonce de
plus en plus. Ça veut dire quoi ?
qu'aujourd'hui après la Corée du Nord,
c'est la Chine qui est devenue le grand
ennemi des USA de monsieur Trump. Parce
que lorsque Obama dit "On va négocier
avec les Iraniens, on va commercialiser
avec les Iraniens, c'est une ouverture."
Trump arrive en disant "Tous ceux qui
ont fait du commerce avec les Iraniens
blacklister aux USA,
ça pose des problèmes."
Mais aujourd'hui, pour en revenir au
conflit syrien, qu'est-ce que l'on a vu
? Poutine
revenir à la 5G.
Ouais, on va revenir à la Poutine, les
Chinois ont prêté ma main forte à la
Syrie parce que Poutine a toutes ses
antennes déployées sur le prochrient en
Syrie et toute sa flotte militaire à
Tartus. Il va pas abandonner même s'il y
a pas Bachar le territoire. Donc il y a
silent incrusté. La 5G aujourd'hui c'est
un enjeu
stratégique. Pourquoi ? Et vous le voyez
bien, les Chinois ont commencé à
distribuer bon des masques, des tques et
tout à toute l'Afrique.
Bon alors je sais pas quelle est leur
qualité et tout. Les Russes sont déjà
présents en Afrique. Centrafrique et
tout où ils offrent un petit peu des
armes pour lutter contre le trafic
d'ivoire mais en même temps ils en
profitent pour vendre un petit peu leur
armement et tout. Attends, les
Américains essayent d'y rentrer. Nous on
recule parce que on a plus les moyens de
rester comme autant de la France Afrique
et autres. C'est vachement important.
Donc les Chinois savent que l'Afrique va
être le continent qui va exploser au
niveau démographique demain où vont se
faire
des affaires économiques plus haut
niveau. Deuxièmement, ils sont déjà
présents sur tout le BTP. Ils ont des
gens placés qui vous font ça
gratuitement, ils se payent après et
tout.
il joue comme une première puissance qui
va aller s'installer en donnant des
moyens et surtout toute la capacité
internet et tous les grands flux qui
sont nécessaires aujourd'hui pour tous
les échanges commerciaux et la
mondialisation.
Donc il y a une vraie guerre au niveau
de la 5G
de capacités de communication mais aussi
d'interception vice-versa et
réciproquement.
Non parce que la 5G on a on a un
technicien qui veut creuser un peu plus
le sujet question interception. Bon, je
suis pas grand technicien mais je vois à
peu près où ils veulent en venir.
Revenons à la vie privée et et surtout
au fait que potentiellement les services
peuvent se se révéler service politique.
Je repose la question.
Non, pas du tout.
Est-ce que les services
Alors, je vais vous dire
du temps de votre époque, avant, après,
pendant, ce que vous voulez,
est-ce que il n'y a pas un petit peu de
petit goût de police politique ?
Absolument pas.
Euh,
regardez-moi encore dans les yeux.
Non mais il y a aucun problème. Vous
pouvez me mettre des projecteurs et
autres, me titiller la plante des pieds.
Non,
si vous voulez, vous êtes dans un
système
éta censé faire un interrogatoire façon
si rien. Vous vous rappelez ?
Ah oui, mais alors là, il faut un peu
plus de temps,
presque un peu plus que le confinement.
Mais
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la torture
?
Ça sert à rien.
Ça sert à rien. C'est inutile. Et vous
pouvez dire n'importe quoi pour faire
plaisir à vos à vos
aux gens qui vous travaillent pour que
ça ça non c'est pas c'est pas un sujet.
on peut travailler beaucoup plus
psychologiquement euh les les intéressés
sans sans problème. Il suffit de bien
connaître leur environnement et leur
écosystème. La vie privée aujourd'hui,
elle est quand même très réglementée.
Je vous coupe parce que la vie privée,
on s'en fout un peu, hein.
Oui. Non, mais
est-ce qu'il y a une puissance qui a
cherché à vous tamponner ?
Jamais. Pas ce jour, sauf vous.
Je suis d'une puissance.
Oh ! À peine la partie visible.
La partie visible de qui ?
Je sais pas. C'est vous qui allez me le
dire.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ici là ?
drapeau français.
D'accord.
Ben bravo, on a le même. Ça tombe bien.
Et ben voilà. Mais vous aussi, vous avez
fait l'objet de fantasme. Vous pouvez
pas de qui ?
Oh, il suffit de de de lire de temps en
temps la presse. On vous voit de c, de
là et autre. Vous avez votre autonomie,
votre indépendance et vous êtes là. Et
vous êtes
Dites-vous bien que si on me voit, c'est
que j'ai bien voulu.
Très bien. Mais bien sûr, mais en plus
c'est un canal je dirais d'information
qui est pertinent.
C'est là le la valeur ajoutée que vous
amenez puisque vous dépendez de
personne, même si on essaie de vous
mettre et de vous astiquer, je dirais,
sur tel ou tel truc, mais c'est ce qui
fait la force et c'est ce qui fait
l'intérêt d'être là aussi.
qui non on irait tout à fait ailleurs
comme on le fait puisqu'on est vous
savez demande de faire des interviews,
passer devant des des des chaînes de
télé pour donner des aspects techniques
ou même des des collègues ministères ou
même des des des journaux étrangers et
tout. Donc on le fait volontiers mais de
temps en temps parce qu'il faut savoir
rester aussi technique. C'est
d'ailleurs mon réalisateur me dit pour
les podcasts n'oubliez pas de nous
sponsoriser sur Tipi. C'est ce qui fait
notre indépendance et notre force.
J'espère que le messena est galopant.
Le messena et nous donne
on peut y participer volonté liberté.
Revenons à nos moutons.
Oui.
Euh l'intelligence économique, elle en
est où en France ?
C'est un sujet qui a démarré en retard
sous l'impulsion
Robert Guillaume
Oui. Et Mart
et de Bernard Rezember.
Martre aussi qui a eu qui a qui a été
quand même
prédisposant au départ. Aujourd'hui,
c'est communément admis.
Il a été créé une délégation
interministérielle à l'intelligence
économique, hein. Donc ça a été acté.
Euh il y a des des flux de la
sensibilisation qui partent au niveau
des entreprises. La DGSI fait partie des
acteurs, la gendarmerie ADGSE à
l'extérieur aussi. Donc ça commence à
être pris en compte mais on a du retard
par rapport à nos partenaires européens
qui ont agi sur le sujet de façon
offensive depuis très longtemps.
Donc aujourd'hui, oui, ça existe, c'est
perfectible
mais aujourd'hui pour une entreprise
dire qu'elle a fait l'objet d'un
tamponnage ou qu'elle s'est fait piller
des données, c'est encore il y a encore
un peu de pudeur, on n'ose pas le dire.
Donc il faut essayer de sensibiliser au
maximum les entreprises sensibles pour
qu'il y ait des retours. Et c'est tout
le boulot de la DGSI qui va faire, je
dirais du porte à porte.
On est là, on est référent. Si vous avez
quoi que ce soit, vous nous appelez, on
traite dans la plus grande discrétion
parce que lorsque ça sort, je dirais par
WordPress et tout,
vous avez bien compris que les intérêts
économiques, le cours de bourse et tout,
bah tout le monde est plombé.
Donc il y a une espèce de côté français
encore, c'est une culture où on n'est
pas encore à ces murs pour dire "Oui, je
me suis fait avoir par telle ou telle
personne."
C'est toute la problématique. Mais on y
arrive péniblement, on y arrive parce
qu'on est dans de la compétitivité
industrielle.
Et le renseignement à qui dans ce
domaine ? Bah c'est 4 ou 5 années
d'économie en terme financier.
C'est surtout des chômeurs.
Et ensuite pour le côté national des
chômeurs.
Vous connaissez le vieil adage ?
Lequel ?
En temps de guerre
que Oui.
C'est quoi le vieil adage ? chômeurs
les chômeurs coûtent plus cher que les
morts.
Oui. Et c'est un petit peu ce qui se
passe pendant le virus aussi hein où là
on en est à traquer
les escrocs au chômage partiel. On a
compris que l'état providence existe. Il
est là en tant que de besoin et là ça a
bien réagi. On a élargi le domaine de
prédilection mais maintenant on
s'aperçoit qu'on est allé très loin et
que certains en profit. Mais là encore,
c'est le côté français qui reprend le
dessus. Donc on va distribuer des
gifles.
On passe du cocalan. On reviendra sur ce
sujet juste après. Euh l'affaire
tarnaque coupa, c'est quoi ? C'est c'est
euh
je peux parler trivialement ? Je peux
parler vulgairement ? Oui, bien sûr.
C'est c'est trois branleurs qui
voulaient faire plaisir à leur
hiérarchie. C'est un dossier qui a été
monté pour faire plaisir à son
président. Alors
c'est quoi ? Je veux être très clair.
Ouais, dites-moi.
Très très clair là-dessus parce que je
l'ai vécu. On m'a mis on m'a scotché euh
dans le dos des trucs.
Quand j'arrive le 1er juillet euh non le
15 euh le 15 juillet ou 16 juillet 2008
à ma prise de fonction officielle à la
tête de la direction de la surveillance
du territoire.
Donc je suis dans mon domaine et tout.
pardon 2007
en 2008 est créé la DCRI et en 2008 Joel
Bouchit le directeur central des RG me
donne un dossier dans lequel il me dit
voilà
on est sur un dossier de
plutôt teinté ultra gauche et haute qui
sont en train de de de vouloir faire les
camps et tout mais tout a été
judiciarisé auprès de la DNAT la
direction la division nationale anti
petit terrorise DCPJ qui est juste à
côté et donc c'est pour information. Je
dis "Ah bon ben voilà, il y a pas de
problème."
Puis cette affaire bon ne nous concerne
moins dans la DCRI mais à un moment il y
a des liaisons je dirais entre les gens
des RG que j'ai récupéré au sein de la
DST et donc de la nouvelle DCRI et la
DNAT qui continue donc à faire de la
procédure quand survient en je sais pas
quelle année bon les opérations de
sabotage des voies ferrées
où là j'apprends qu'il y a manifestement
un sentiment de réactivité un peu plus
démesuré que d'habitude de la part
Guillaume Pepi, patron de la SNCF
qui demande à Michelomarie, le ministre
intérieur de l'époque de mettre en place
une réunion de travail immédiate avec le
procureur de la République à laquelle je
participe pas. Moi, j'apprendrai ça bien
après. Donc si pour vous montrer le
degré de
de de
connaissance de ce ce sujet euh
et donc là, il décide de confier une
affaire en flagrant d'élit à la
gendarmerie. Quand j'apprends ça le
lendemain, je dis bah attendez mais je
crois de me souvenir que cette affaire
est déjà confiée à la DCPJ. Donc de là,
le parquet gère son truc et ensuite ça
part sur
quelque chose qui était une erreur pour
novembre des interpellations immédiates
alors que on était au début du
commencement de bon toujours est-il que
il y avait des éléments matériels mais
comme le diraient les avocats de cette
mouvance
entre l'acte préparatoire le
commencement d'exécution la tentative et
tout il y a large faisceau. Bon peu
importe. Donc cette affaire elle est
révélateur de quoi ? bah un mouvement de
contestation d'intellectuel de haut
niveau tout qui prend forme et tout que
qui a été je dirais empêché. Il y a eu
des erreurs au niveau des horaires de
filature des non non
p de surveillance tout ça fait partie du
ça s'appelle pas trafiquer des PV ça ?
Non mais pas du tout. Mais attendez si
vous saviez comment
c'estàdire la filature qui était là le
mec était
la filature était exacte. Deuxièmement
les achats dans de per et de machin
d'outils techniqu enfin je sais plus
lesquels ont bien été vu et récupéré par
les surveillances. Non mais peu importe.
OK. le le problème tout il y a eu
une relaxe générale et tout, il y a pas
de problème, les avocats ont été très
bons. Des
sanctions du côté des fonctionnaires,
je ne sais pas moi
où il y a eu des des promotions.
Promotion de quoi ? Non, j'en sais rien,
absolument pas.
Peut-être quelque chose sur lequel il
faut aller voir. Mais toujours est-il
que l'ultra gauche en général en France
représente quand même quelque chose de
réel ? Premier point. Est-ce que pour
vous l'ultra gauche est un danger avec
le déconfinement, la colère sociale ?
Est-ce qu'il y a une insurrection qui
vient ?
Alors, non seulement c'est réel, mais
c'est écrit par les intéressés eux-mêmes
et ils le disent au effort puisque le
confinement, qu'est-ce que ça a fait ?
Ça n'a fait que amplifier un phénomène
que l'on a interrompu par un débat
parlementaire
après une longue crise des gilets
jaunes.
Euh débordement black block que vous
avez suivi là-dessus. Réforme des
retraites. Donc il y avait un
un mécontentement général.
On arrête avec le débat parlementaire,
on laisse passer de mois. Aujourd'hui,
on réouvre les vannes. Entre-temps, on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a eu des exactions,
des sabotages de c de là, d'abord dans
la région de Grenoble qui qui a toujours
été un peu plus activiste que d'autres.
Et aujourd'hui, on s'aperçoit qu'on
cible quoi ? L'État régalien, brigade de
gendarmerie, commissariat de police,
le capitalisme, les banques,
secteur de l'énergie, analys, EDF, tout
ça. Euh et les réseaux sociaux.
Internet. Internet pourquoi ? Parce
qu'il permet au capitalisme en pleine
période de confinement de continuer à
travailler par le télétravail
mais également de mettre en place ce que
vous appelez l'état policier, la
vidéosurveillance, la gestion des
fichiers et autres. Donc
c'est l'état policier non ?
Oui. Non mais il faut aussi un état
policier. Vous allez accepter que les
black block cassent tout Paris sans rien
bouger, sans rien faire.
Black Block les black sont 1000 en
France.
Ouais. Ils sont c'est un C'est pas le
chiffon rouge qu'on agite pour eu
mais pas du tout mais le black block ils
ont existé pour les grands sommets de
l'OTAN et tout.
Oui. C'est une amicale une méthodologie
d'emploi qui se fait avec nos amis
allemands, italiens et tout mais ils
s'entretiennent comme ça. Bah voilà mais
mais c'est ennuyeux au niveau quand même
du résultat qui est l'ultra gauche black
block. Ils sont pas tellement nombreux.
C'est pour la plupart c'est pour la
plupart des étudiants en licence de
machin des voies de garage. Ouais. C'est
des gamins qui sont pas bien méchants.
Non,
il y a de tout.
Il y a de tout.
Il y a de tout mais il y a aussi la
mouvance ultra gauche autonome qui a
toujours existé sur pas le chiffon rouge
qu'on utilise pour
pas du tout
éradiquer nos libertés en France.
Attz
sur l'histoire des libertés
avec la loi sur le renseignement la
légalisation des opérations spéciales
à postéri
sur la lutte antiterroriste.
Les gens ont applaudi la police, ont
fait voter les lois, tout s'est passé
aujourd'hui sur le tracing qui est un
échelon supplémentaire au tit de la
santé. Les gens sont pas d'accord.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on les on les a
baisé dans le passé. Non.
Ah ben oui, mais c'est là où aujourd'hui
il y a une évolution technologique mais
l'évolution légale et réglementaire
tarde et essaie de recoller au pleut.
Mais la technologie fait bien plus de
choses. Mais vous prenez un hackur
puisque vous semblez bien connaître, je
dirais le domaine, mais vous faites des
choses 100 fois plus dangereuses
que ce que peuvent faire les services
dans un cadre légal et réglementaire. Je
suis désolé.
Vous avez suivi quand vous travaillez ?
Pas du tout. Vos collègues m'ont suivi.
C'est possible.
Mais vous savez les hackurs,
ce sont des amis.
C'est des amis depuis quand ?
Depuis longtemps.
Depuis qu'on les a mis au trou ?
Ah non, pas du tout. Pas du tout. Il y a
des gens, vous savez, qui coopent
parfaitement avec les services.
C'est pas souvent les meilleurs.
Comment ?
Mais si, justement, mais un meilleur ne
dure que de ou 3 ans. Après, il
s'estompe, il faut en trouver un autre.
Regardez un
Et vous en faites quoi ? Vous en faites
quoi une fois que vous l'avez pompé et
sauré pendant 3 ans ?
Ils nous apprennent des choses sur le
plan technologique, technique et tout.
Bon, c'est tout. On apprend avec eux en
même temps.
On est sur de la recherche.
Mais aujourd'hui, sur le plan
technologique, ça vous a pas échappé
puisque vous suivez très bien le
problème.
Les grandes les F, le réseau échelon et
la NSA en primoté. puisque c'est le le
leader essae de de de contrôler un petit
peu tous les flux les métadonnées qui
passent de c de là pour ensuite les
utiliser en tant que de besoin. Bon,
Snowden le révèle de façon parfaite dans
le détail
mais aujourd'hui le patriote tac permet
tout ça. Bon nous cette technologie à
l'avance mais on n pas le cadre
réglementaire qui vient soutendre tout
ça. Donc il faut rattraper et travailler
avec le retard. C'est tout.
Revenons à la mouvance d'ultra gauche.
Euh pour si vous deviez faire un
classement
des menaces en terme insurrectionnel,
est-ce que l'ultra gauche est dans le
top ? Est-ce que la radicalisation
religieuse est dans le top ten Qu'est-ce
qui vous fait le plus peur ? la
radicalisation du libéralisme.
Alors, je pense que on a une menace
prignante qui est tout à fait diffuse
mais de très haut niveau par nos
interventions militaires bien sûr, par
nos prises de position. C'est la menace
islamiste radicale.
La menace ultra gauche n'est pas en
général une menace mais il y a des gens
qui à l'intérieur veulent en découdre.
Vous parlez de l'insurrection et autres.
Oui, on reparle en ce moment de l'action
directe. Ça rappelle des souvenirs, un
savoir-faire, des échanges, une branche
internationaliste, une branche
nationale.
Tout ça c'est pas bon. Ça veut pas dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a quelque chose,
mais demain peut-être. Oui, mais je
laisse le soin au service de travailler
sur ces sujets qui nécessitent aussi une
coopération internationale parce que ça
existe aussi dans les pays un petit peu
autour. Quand vous voyez que la
gendarmerie
développe un appareil spécial pour
suivre les écolos.
Ah non, mais la gendarmerie travaille au
niveau judiciaire de façon très
militaire. Elle crée des cellules
dédiées. Voilà. Bon mais non mais c'est
leur c'est leur méthodologie, c'est leur
façon, c'est comme l'armée. Bon alors je
sais pas si c'est bon c'est mauvais, je
m'aventurerai pas sur ce chemin, mais
elle travaille en judiciaire mais euh
euh je dirais euh de façon chalutage
quoi. C'est c'est on prend tout ce qui
vient. Je vois à quoi vous faites
allusion, bur et tout ce qui est
contestation et tout.
Oui, disons que on déploie de gros
moyens parce qu'on craint des troubles à
l'ordre public et donc on travaille sur
du relationnel très élargi. Bon,
si on a les moyens, pourquoi pas ? Mais
bon, en général dans les services de
renseignement et avec la spécialisation
que l'on a, non, je vous
c'est plutôt tenu et très ciblé.
Vous me permettez, je vais vous
reprendre. On craint des troubles à
l'ordre public. Oui, votre gibin vous
attend. Je je vous trouve quand même
très chameau. Euh
on on va parler de bur des troubles à
l'ordre public, mais c'est pas des
troubles à l'ordre du PIB. C'est-à-dire
la France la France est une puissance
nucléaire.
La France n'a aucun intérêt d'avoir un
mouvement contestataire autour du
nucléaire.
Tout le monde
Est-ce que c'est pour ça qu'on est en
train de mettre des laisses à la patte
de nous ?
Écoutez, vous avez vécu plogof.
Hm hm.
C'était avant 80. Bon, il se trouve que
l'alternance a donné beaucoup de
ministres breton et Plot Gof a été
enterré.
Ensuite, on produit du nucléaire, on
produit IER aussi à Cadarche qui est le
côté international et tout. Mais à un
moment, il faut pouvoir enfuire aussi
tous ces déchets nucléaires. Et c'est là
où survient tout le problème. Les décès
de de de
lag sont recyclés à Cadarche. Il faut
escorter à chaque fois tous les convois
qui viennent et tout et qui sont je
dirais recyclés.
de façon assez technique. Donc
aujourd'hui se pose un problème
effectivement savoir ce que l'on veut.
Est-ce qu'on veut repasser au
photovoltaïque à l'éolien euh
non plus à l'électrique hein, vous avez
bien compris au côté marimutrice aussi.
Enfin je sais pas c'est c'est un choix
mais le choix ne dépend pas de moi. Le
problème c'est qu'à chaque fois on a des
mouvements de contestation. Alors tant
que c'est que politique contestateur ça
va.
Le jour où ça devient à caractère, je
dirais beaucoup plus offensif, là ça
intéresse les services bien sûr,
mais la contestation politique, elle est
permise au parlement. Il y a des gens
qui sont représentés et ça pose pas de
problème.
Quand quand François Ruffin annonce
qu'il a les services sur son sur son dos
pour un dossier de sédition
de sédition,
je vois pas lequel.
Vous savez, on a interpellé, j'ai vu
récemment Charles Hançon,
le gilet jaune de Carpentra qui s'est
mis à appeler à la révolte avec des
généraux, je sais pas lesquels, pour
marcher sur l'Élysée et prendre le
pouvoir.
Gu c'est un guignol.
Oui, mais je le sais que c'est
quelqu'un, je dirais, qu'il faut prendre
à son niveau dans le contexte régional.
Carpentra. Bon, la vallée de la naise
tout ça. De là, on lui met bon, il y a
une enquête qui est diligente et bien
sûr, mais des moyens nationaux qui sont
mis, la BRI nationale et tout. Bon,
bravo. Je pense qu'on a peut-être
d'autres sujets prioritaires. Enfin, je
sais pas, c'est une appréciation
personnelle.
C'était une façon de de de discréditer
le mouvement des gilets jaunes en le
laissant faire sa remontada jusqu'à la
porte d'Italie. On était en pleine
période de déconfinement. Bon, c'est le
retour à la liberté et voilà, on reprend
les gilunes. Il y a eu quelques
rassemblements
malgré l'interdiction de rassemblement à
plus de 10 personnes et tout qui ont été
dispersé par la police. Donc le
mouvement le mouvement reste encore je
dirais à l'état embryonnaire mais peut
redémarrer.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des gilets
jaunes ? C'est un mouvement qui est
légitime ? C'est c'est les anticorps de
la France face à un capitalisme qui
dégrade l'humanité qui
je crois qu'on est
on est vous savez on a connu dans la
mine de la mondialisation.
Non mais c'est pas ça. On a connu les
cahiers de doléance à l'époque de la
révolution. Bon que Rome prenne garde à
la colère des légions. La France
profonde la fracture sociale. Oui. Il y
a des métiers qui sont dévalorisés. que
il y a une pouvoir d'achat qui est
dévalorisé en certains endroits. Vous
prenez le 93, la région PACA, Marseille
et tout des endroits où je suis passé.
La Creuse.
Oui, la Creuse. Il y a des sujets. Vous
avez des jeunes paysans agriculteurs qui
s'endettent pour faire vivre des
exploitations et qui finissent par se
suicider. C'est pas normal.
Aujourd'hui, on va aider les personnels
soignants, on va aider les les premiers
qui ont assuré la continuité de
l'activité économique. Oui, il y a un
problème social en France, on peut pas
le nier.
Donc la colère des gilets jaunes, elle
est, je dirais,
légitime et il faut l'étudier. Et
d'ailleurs, les préfets avaient fait
remonter dans leur rapport hebdomadaire
tout ce sentiment qu'ils sentaient là
encore la profité.
fait très bien aussi
bien sûr mais on en a pas tenu compte,
on a sous-estimé et ensuite est arrivé
la bouffée déligrante avec les
manifestation sur les Champs élysées. On
a vu ce que ça a donné ensuite le noir.
Pour vous traiter ça de bouffée
délirante
mais parce qu'à un moment la réunion de
tous ces gens-là fait qu'il y a un
sentiment d'insatisfaction et on veut
montrer au pouvoir centralisateur qu'on
est là, qu'on compte et qu'on sait il va
falloir compter avec nous. Donc c'est
quelque chose qui a qui a gonflé
naturellement.
On va rebattre les cartes histoire de
vous mélanger mais vous êtes quand même
un poisson difficile.
Alstom
Alstom.
Qu'est-ce qui a fait les le
contre-espionnage français dans
l'affaire Alstom ?
Moi j'ai rien fait.
Non mais ça on s'en serait bien douté.
Est-ce que d'autres ont fait quelque
chose ?
C'est possible.
Qui ?
Alors dites-moi de quoi il s'agit
exactement. Et je
vous connaissez l'affaire. Il y en a
plusieurs affaires à stom.
Alors, vous préférez laquelle ?
Ah non, mais
là où il y a de la forfaiture ou là où
on se fait dépouiller ? Alst, ce sont
des gens qui ont
la grandeur de la France à travers le
TGV déjà d'une part qui l'ont vendu au
niveau international. Ça c'est le le
gros point, qui se sont fait goer sur
des affaires de corruption de c de là et
autre.
Pour le reste, après moi je m'en suis
pas occupé mais j'étais pas le seul
service à gérer tout ça, rassurez-vous.
Pas plus,
pas plus,
pas plus.
Amenez-moi la batte de baseball là. Pas
de problème.
On on va parler on va parler
intelligence artificielle,
reconnaissance faciale. Est-ce que pour
vous ce sont des aides de camp de du
renseignement ou c'est simplement des
artifices pour se faire poutrer par des
puissances étrangères ?
Je vais être encore plus pragmatique.
Vous êtes agent à la DGSE
comme vous savez
bien sûr undercover. Ça veut dire que
vous avez une fausse identité,
vous passez deci de là et un jour on
vous met de la reconnaissance faciale et
votre faux passeport biométrique et ben
il résiste pas. Ça veut dire qu'il suff
être marié à une américaine ou à une
russe mais le jour où vous voulez aller
voir votre belle-mère, c'est plus
possible parce que votre biométrie et
ben elle va réapparaître.
Donc je pose vraiment le problème au
bout des choses pour le citoyen normal.
une reconnaissance faciale, on le voit
en Chine, les apports, les intérêts, les
inconvénients, bah vous êtes hyper
plombé, hein. C'est c'est exactement le
la solution à laquelle il faut pas
arriver. Il y a plus de liberté, c'est
évident puisque Big Brother permet les
croisements de fichiers si on veut, la
reconnaissance, votre géolo tout tout
tout.
C'est dangereux. Ah oui, c'est dangereux
quand on évolue dans une société qui a
une
une perspective économique
difficile pour ne pas dire délétaire.
Est-ce que le pouvoir politique risque
de se radicaliser à Est-ce que le
pouvoir politique risque de se
radicaliser
à cause d'une situation économique qui
ne va plus pouvoir gérer avec
subordination de vote et je vous en
passe des meilleurs ? Est-ce qu'il va
tenter de s'appuyer sur cette canne
informatique, cette canne technologique
pour pouvoir imposer le calme ?
Personnellement, je ne le pense pas. Et
la culture française et l'opinion
française plaît dans ce sens et puis nos
représentants à l'Assemblée, au Sénat
sont très circonspis.
C'est quoi être français ?
Ah, c'est être frondeur. On attend la
règle pour mieux pouvoir la contourner.
Mais ça ça a toujours été.
C'est le français.
C'est ce qui fait son charme. Multiplier
par 95 départements et dommes, ça vous
donne autant de frondeur.
Mais c'est la il y a pas que les
fromages et le vin, il y a aussi tout
ça, toutes les différences de caractère.
Moi il posa la question si j'étais
français ou je suis français et Corse
aussi. Mais parce qu'on a chacun son
caractère. D'où êtes-vous vous-même ?
D'où je vous parle ? Ouais, vous
revendez un pied en Corse, un pied en
Bourgogne. C'est ça.
Ouais. Donc vous avez une attache
quelque part qui vous ramène toujours à
vos fondamentaux et avec tout ce qui va
avec. Et ce qui est logique puisquil
faut pas perdre son âme. Faut surtout
garder les racines et faut toujours
savoir d'où on vient, faut jamais
oublier.
Euh je regarde juste ma petite fiche.
Vous savez quand quand
Ah, vous avez des fiches mais elles sont
pas déclarées à l'acnil. Non non, vous
savez, je je vais vous raconter une
histoire euh et puis on va raconter
l'histoire à la communauté en même
temps.
Quand j'ai bossé sur votre sur votre
interview,
ah
j'ai été obligé de faire 98 % de tête
parce que j'avais peur
qu'on me pone ma fiche et qu'on vous
informe des questions que j'allais vous
poser.
Alors, écoutez, personnellement, j'ai
rien demandé.
Deuxièmement, je viens très volontiers
parce que c'est un support qui est très
intéressant et hor
connaiss la Vous connaissiez la chaîne
avant ?
Oui. Oui. Ouais. J'aimais bien. J'aimais
bien. J'avais vu des gens passer et
tout. Bon et
tout repose sur l'autre format l'autre
format d'information.
Il y a la police qui est en train de
taper en
Oui, pas de problème. Ils viennent de
vous arrêter parce que je leur ai donné
mais je leur ai dit à la fin de
l'interview he simplement.
C'est vrai. Donc c'est pas terminé, vous
pouvez rentrer chez vous. Et donc si
vous voulez euh
vous aborder les choses différemment en
toute indépendance, ce qui change un
petit peu des figures contraintes
imposées
par rapport aux grandes chaînes et
autres et puis dont on se lasse. C'est
vrai parce que bon en période de
confinement
vous êtes sur des supports plus
originaux et on va préférer ce que vous
faites à d'autres à d'autres choses. un
petit peu l'histoire
Booba qui était quelque chose d'original
mais qui avait l'avantage
de pas perdre son temps et de faire
passer un message au effort grâce à
quelqu'un qui avait la légitimité. C'est
c'est ça le sujet.
Euh on arrive à la moitié de notre
interview maintenant qu'on a fait les
préliminaires.
Oui. Cétait le préchauffage.
Ouais.
Je vais être obligé de vous poser des
questions un peu plus franco.
Oui.
Pourquoi la justice vous emmerde en ce
moment ?
Ah, ça on remonte à l'époque de notre
gouvernement.
Manifestement, on est sur
euh comment dirais-je ? Tout le système
sarcit purgé. D'abord le ministère de
l'intérieur, ensuite les autres. faut
empêcher peut-être le retour en
politique de et des équipes. Bon voilà
donc il y a des choses qui spécialement
ont été créé pour j'en ai eu la preuve
pourquoi
au niveau du parquet au niveau de parce
qu'il y avait des instructions au plus
haut niveau. Voilà
n'est pas indépendant bien sûr. Ah non,
parquet n'a jamais été indépendant que
je sache et d'ailleurs c'est un sujet
euh qu'il relevait au niveau euh
européen.
Donc euh là-dessus, je laisse les
avocats gérer tout ça et les juristes,
la doctrine, la jurisprudence et autres.
Bon euh
toujours est-il que
bon, il y avait un
un sujet, c'est vrai.
Moi, j'ai été mis hors cadre avec
Frédéric Péchnard. le directeur général
de la police nationale Michel Godin le
préfet de police de Paris sans
explication. Bon ok ça fait partie du
statut. Bon ben en général on a une
explication.
Frédéric Pennard a été recasé à la
sécurité routière. Michel Godin au
Conseil d'État puis après ils ont quitté
et puis moi j'ai rien eu. Alors je vais
vous raconter comment ça s'est passé.
Euh, on est euh bon, j'avais comment
dirais-je commencé à vider toutes mes
armoir comme dirait l'autre, mais
j'avais gardé encore les affaires
courantes.
C'est ce qu'on a retrouvé dans votre
coffre.
Oui, bien sûr. Les affaires courantes
parce que
je peux vous couper ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Est-ce que un directeur de renseignement
quand il quitte son service, il part
avec son assurance, c'est-à-dire des
fiches sur tout le monde ? Non, pas du
tout. Mais je garde mes affaires
personnelles parce que j'en ai.
Deuxièmement, je garde les affaires
courantes et troisièmement, quand on est
comment dirais-je
expulsé en 48 he on n pas le temps de
faire le ménage. Je m'explique, j'ai
reçu un ordre de dégarerpire. Très bien.
Ça fera certainement sourire certain.
Déjà pendant pendant la période
électorale, j'ai lu le nouvel et autre
où on disait que François Hollande,
candidat donc qui allait remporter le
truc.
voulez ma tête et celle d'Henry
Progliot.
Donc j'ai appelé Henri Progliot en
disant je suis désolé, je te tire vers
le bas parce que bon te lâche pareil, je
suis bon voilà donc on sentait bien.
Donc j'avais commencé à faire un petit
peu mes trier mes trucs. Mais vous savez
le soir ou le matin très tôt on est
appelé, il faut avoir le fond de
dossier. Les collaborateurs sont pas
toujours là. Donc, j'avais mes dossiers
que j'avais constitué personnellement
mais sur des dossiers en cours, que ce
soit l'islam radical, la coopération et
le Sahel, enfin des choses de tous les
jours mais que je gardais dans mon
bureau parce qu'après tout est fermé,
les secrétaires sont plus là et puis moi
j'étais du matin et du soir. Voilà. La
BNP aussi non ?
Comment ?
À la BNP non.
Oh non, mais là il y avait pas
grand-chose. On y reviendra si vous
voulez. Donc deuxièmement
euh on est appelé avec Frédéric Penard
pour accompagner le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur, monsieur Vals,
qui avait remplacé au pied levé monsieur
Rsamen, qui était prévu et qui avait
organisé euh toutes ses équipes hein. Je
l'avais vu auparavant à sa demande, il
m'a expliqué, je lui avais fait le point
sur la réforme et tout mais il était
parfaitement au courant. Il m'a dit "On
vous gardera pas mais on vous traitera."
Mais je dis "Mais attendez, je suis pas
titulaire de mon poste, c'est tout à
fait normal. et continuer la réforme
parce que c'est important pour la
sécurité de la France.
Et on apprend qu'il faut partir avec le
nouveau ministre intérieur en Espagne.
Alors l'Espagne a basculé de gauche,
elle est passée à droite ce qui est
assez rigolo et nous droite on est passé
à gauche.
Donc on accompagne le ministre avec son
son cabinet et on va rencontrer les
homologue du ministère de l'intérieur
espagnol pour parler de choses que l'on
connaissait, la lutte anti puisque bon
depuis les années 90
[Musique]
mais on y est arrivé grâce à un peu de
détermination.
Euh
le matin donc il y a la la réunion
déjeuner et ensuite
le cabinet nous dit ce sera privé, on va
à l'ambassade, le ministre a des
réunions politiques et comment dirais-je
vous attendra à côté puis on reprendra
l'avion de ligne normalement.
Donc on se retrouve dans les salons de
l'ambassade de France à Madrid tout à
fait
calmement et tout. On attend que
les premiers jours et l'été et le soleil
apparaissant,
les le cabinet travail avec le ministre
et ses homologues espagnols
dans les jardins
de l'ambassade
et un moment
sort de la terrasse et vient dans
l'intérieur de l'ambasse.
pour les satisfaire un besoin naturel.
Le ministre de l'intérieur espagnol qui
me reconnaît, il me dit "Mais qu'est-ce
que tu fous là ?" "J'accompagne mon
ministre."
Et alors non mais moi je dirais c'est
fini là on termine
on on
on va clôturer et puis tu travailleras
avec une autre équipe. Bon
il me dit attends il
il revient il me dit viens avec moi. Je
fais non non si si. Il me dit viens avec
moi. Il vient al je découvre la table en
techque la réunion politique avec
le ministre d'intérieur qui était le
responsable du PSOE. au niveau position
nouvelle et tout et il dit il dit tu
vois lui c'est un ami parce que il a
travaillé avec nous il nous a apporter
une aide avec ses équipes bien sûr pas
seul il dit c'est un petit bien il faut
le garder et là Manuel Vas dit non c'est
impossible écouté ma place n'est pas là
merci au revoir et tout je repars dans
l'avion du retour avec Frédéric Péchard
on dit bon alors monsieur le ministre
c'est mardi soir demain il y a conseil
des ministres vous avez l'ordre du jour
donc C'est demain qu'on est viré, c'est
pour pouvoir
préparer euh son départ et tout. Non,
non, bien sûr que non. Non, non, mais je
vous le dirai et tout. Et le lendemain,
on la prend par la presse et le
communiqué de presse
du gouvernement après le conseil des
ministres.
Trouvez ça un peu bizarre.
Et je reçois comme Péchnard et Godin.
Godin lui, il a eu un appel le soir même
de son successeur lui demandant de
laisser l'appartement le bureau pour le
lendemain. Alors que la tradition
républicaine dans la préfectorale, c'est
15 jours de vacances, on prépare ces
choses, on trie, on ne se rencontre pas
et ensuite
le successeur vient prendre sa place et
faire le boulot.
Nous, on a reçu un ordre d'égar pire
pour les 48 he qu'est-ce que vous faites
? Parce que vous continuez à bosser
parce que les équipes sont toujours là
et demandent et autres. Bah, j'ai tout
ramassé les gardes du corps ont tout
récupéré, ont tout ramené chez moi et
j'ai pas trié. C'est resté à la cave
puisque j'ai changé d'appartement et
autres. Et voilà ce qu'on a trouvé. Et
le seul dossier que j'avais mis au
coffre de la BNP, c'était un dossier sur
le nucléaire iranien. J'avais dit à
Calvar, c'est pour toi, il faut que je
te le rende parce que c'est quelque
chose de très important. No auditeurs
qui est Calvar.
Calvar Patrick Calvar est un collègue
qui était mon ancien adjoint qu'on a
nommé directeur du renseignement la DGSE
et que Valse
pour assurer une continuum je dirais de
l'activité de renseignement à nommer à
ma place. Bon, quelqu'un je dirais que
je connais parfaitement bien, qui est un
ami, qui est un très bon professionnel
et donc je dit il faut que je te rende
ce dossier et tout. Il me dit "Ouais, tu
as le temps et tout puis il y en a
d'autres aussi." Bon ça s'est passé
comme ça jusqu'au jour où par suite de
aussi ce concomitant. Mais on va y
revenir si on a le temps, hein.
Je suis dessinataire de renseignement
très pointu, laissant entendre qu'une
équipe qui n'est pas d'aucune depuis la
France va s'installer au Gabon pour
préparer un coup d'état contre Sasun
Gesso
avec le général Mokoco et autres tout.
Bon, on avait alors quand vous
connaissez la rivalité entre le Gabon et
Congo
Braza, vous voyez un petit peu ce que ça
peut donner. Bon, j'ai des éléments. On
avait formé à l'époque le chef de la
garde présidentielle de Sassounesso que
je connais pas
et je l'appelle en disant tiens j'ai des
éléments,
tu fais ce que tu veux, quand tu passes
à Paris, tu viens et donc il les prend,
ça s'avère vrai et autres.
Euh
le coup d'état est démonté,
l'équipe au Gabon est largement
identifiée et autres. elle sera
condamné. Ce sont c'est une entreprise
d'intelligence économique française
qui rigue les plus haut niveaux de
l'État. Mais bon voilà,
tu connais ?
Oh, je sais pas. Et donc tout ceci finit
en en boudin et au bout d'un mois,
on me demande d'aller rendre visite à
Sassound Gesso et tout. Bon, je finis
par y aller
pour lui expliquer qu'il a des trous
dans la raquette, que s'il a besoin,
on peut lui rectifier le format de ses
services de renseignement au Canba que
je connais bien et tout. On peut faire
un truc m' dit bon je réfléchir et tout
puis voilà et retour je fais l'objet
d'une fouille approfondiode pensant que
je ramenais de l'argent pour Nicolas
Sarkozi ou je ne sais qui mais que nén
je n'avais rien sur moi et le lendemain
j'ai droit à des perquisitions et autres
et on on cherche plein de choses et tout
alors ce qu'il y a par voie de presse et
ce qu'il y a dans le dossier sont des
choses très différentes mais compte tenu
du secret de l'instruction vous
comprendrez que voilà
combien il gagnent Bernard Scourcini,
pardon.
Combien il gagne Bernard Scorcini ?
Comme un préfet, je me suis mis dans ma
société au même niveau qu'un préfet.
C'est combien ?
C'est autour de 11000 € par mois.
Net, brut,
net.
Vous avez un patrimoine ?
Pas du tout.
Alors,
j'ai eu par voix de succession
une maison familiale qui avait faite mon
grand peur au village encore. C'est ça
veut dire beaucoup de choses.
Un petit terrain qu'on a jamais vendu
parce que les vieux disaient faut jamais
vendre. Ça servait à faire pêtre les
brebis et autres parce que mon
grand-père était agriculteur parce
qu'après la guerre, il avait été estropé
donc il pouvait plus rien faire.
Et j'ai gardé cette maison qui m'a été
dévolue. L'autre moitié à mon frère que
j'ai racheté, lui il a été ailleurs.
Euh
j'ai poussé un peu, j'ai amélioré pour
faire venir les enfants, les
petits-enfants
pour les fixer régulièrement sur cette
notion géographique insulaire.
Une petite maison aussi dans les albes
de Provence qui n'a ni que ni tête. Et
puis j'ai rien du tout à Paris. Je suis
locateur. Voilà. Donc mon train de vie
est très limité.
Avant avant de de vous faire venir ici,
j'ai j'ai fait un peu votre périmètre.
J'ai appelé quelques copains et et j'ai
eu deux sons de cloche différents.
Ouais.
J'ai eu le squal est intruant.
Oui, bien sûr.
J'ai eu euh
Dites-moi les noms et puis je dirai
j'irai les reexpliquer.
J'irai J'ai eu Squarcini et loyal.
Squarcini à une parole.
J'ai eu Squarini
pèse des millions et j'ai eu Squarcini
a tellement de problème avec un contrôle
judiciaire de bâtard qu'il est pas
capable de transférer 400 € à sa fille
sans se faire sans se faire emmerder.
Alors d'une part, on peut transférer
Où est où est Bernard ?
Écoutez, j'ai choisi la fonction
publique.
On m'a interrompu dans ma carrière, je
le regrette.
On m'a forcé à aller dans le privé
puisque pour continuer l'histoire de
monsieur Vals
euh
et voulait me voir tous les mois pour
discuter après ma mise en cadre de
l'analyse sur le terrorisme d'extrême
droite, d'extrême gauche international
enfin bon. À un moment je lui dis mais
attendez, qu'est-ce que vous comptez
faire de moi et tout ? Il dit "J'ai
aucun poste pour vous." Ah bon ? Bah je
dis "Alors, vous me signez ma mise en
diproité." Il me dit "Bah oui, si vous
voulez." Et c'est là où me dit "Mais je
voudrais continuer à vous voir." Oui,
non mais si je suis dans le privé et que
je commence à changer complètement
d'orientation tout en ayant les mêmes
sujets,
je serais obligé de vous facturer. Et
là, il a très mal pris. Ça s'est arrêté
là. Bon, je suis loyal bien sûr et j'ai
toujours défendu le drapeau français
alors que j'aurais pu travailler pour
des puissances étrangères. C'est une
évidence biblique. Deuxièmement, si je
veux travailler
pour aider mes enfants et mes
petits-enfants, c'est bien volontiers
que je le fais. Moi, j'ai aucun besoin,
vous savez. C'est pas parce que j'ai
deux vieilles motos anglaises que j'aime
qui me rappelle ma jeunesse, que j'adore
bricoler ou de la japonaise parce que
voilà, j'ai été jeune motard à l'âge de
16 ans puisqu'on pouvait passer le
permis et le haute cylindré très tôt.
Ensuite, j'ai fait ma facu. Ensuite, je
me suis marié et j'ai passé un concours,
j'ai fait l'armée aussi. Euh j'ai passé
un concours de commissaire et ensuite
parti en Bretagne en Corse au
Pays-Basque, Paris et autres. Région
comment ? Oui, bien sûr. Et turbulente.
Turbulente à forte caractère. Et ensuite
préfet de police Samaria pour revenir.
Vous savez si j'avais choisi d'être
riche ou je sais pas quoi, j'aurais pris
le privé dès le départ comme tous mes
copains de fac qui étaient avec moi sur
les bandes de la fac d'ex en Provence.
Moi, j'ai choisi la fonction publique
parce que j'ai été
j'ai eu une matrice paternelle et
grand-père qui disait la France. C'est
un conseil aux jeunes aussi défendre la
France par
c'est à la fin de l'interview ça
par différents moyens. Mais moi j'ai
choisi ça. On m'a obligé à changer
d'activité.
J'étais pas retraitable. Je suis
toujours en disponibilité. Faut bien que
je vive aussi et que j'
64 ans.
64 ans. Oui, on va jusqu'à 67 au niveau
de la perfectorale. Mais ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire que on va me mettre
une double peine. Je peux encore être
utile pour défendre les intérêts
français comme je pourrais défendre
d'autres intérêts. Mais non, je préfère
être le complément à l'activité des
services que je connais très bien parce
que je n'ai fait ça que plus de 30 ans
dans ma vie. Ce qui est une chance et
une rareté. Et c'est pour ça qu'on me
reproche d'avoir fait du renseignement.
Al mais je crois que faut voir aussi les
gouvernements que j'ai servi et les
lettres de remerciement des premiers
ministres de gauche, de droite et haute
que j'ai dans avec moi. C'est ma seule
reconnaissance
comme les médailles que l'on peut
acquérir au titre de l'aide que l'on a
fourni au service étranger. Et ça c'est
une grande reconnaissance parce qu'on
est plus reconnu à l'étranger que dans
son propre pays parce qu'il y a trop
d'alternance et de règlement de compte
au niveau politique.
Quand on dit euh Bernard Squarini, c'est
un homme de réseau, c'est un homme des
réseaux Corse, c'est un homme qui a
utilisé l'appareil d'état pour son
compte personnel, c'est quelqu'un qui a
Absolument pas. Je suis euh fidèle en
amitié,
j'ai su constitué des équipes de
travailleurs parce que seul vous parlez
de quel ami là ?
Comment
vous parlez de quel ami ?
Amitié. les gens qui sont avec qui vous
êtes en relation
lorsqu'ils sont je dirais en flamboyant,
bah vous les connaissez lorsqu'ils sont
en dessous du niveau de la mer, bah vous
les connaissez aussi, il faut être
fidèle. Faut être fidèle, c'est tout.
Mais c'est la nature humaine qui veut
ça. Donc ensuite que la presse exploite
et tout. Mais vous savez la presse, il y
a de tout aussi. Moi, j'ai connu Yve
Bertrand 12 ans directeur central DRG.
Il y a une liste de journalistes qui
circulent qui venait à la bibliothèque
prendre des dossiers tout fait et en
même temps une petite enveloppe. C'est
ça le journalisme et la déontologie.
Heureusement,
c'est toujours ça.
Ah je ne sais pas moi, je ne suis plus
en état, je dirais aux manettes. Donc
voilà, j'ai connu tout ça. Donc il y a à
boire et à manger, faut faire attention,
faut regarder.
C'est ce que vous nous avez amené là ?
Non, pas du tout. Elle est dans le
coffre mais un autre. Deuxièmement, euh
vous savez les les la presse écrite, la
presse évolue, les réseaux sociaux sont
là et autres. Et puis il y a des gens
qui passent des commandes qui vous
donnent des dossiers étouffés pour
salir, atteindre et tout. C'est du
réseau d'influence ça. Ce sont les
réseaux les pires.
Ça se fait toujours ça ?
Bah bien sûr, il y a des grandes boîtes
de com
avec des cabinets d'avocat
hein. Parisien,
tout est possible. Bah là, on est en
train de travailler sur un ou
tout est possible mais vous savez
tout ce c'est aussi.
Alors, il faut faire attention parce
qu'il suffit
de remonter un petit peu en amont
l'information,
le côté absence de déontologie de
certains journalistes qui vont à la
croque aussi hein, il faut pas croire
puisque la presse est en crise, des gens
qui écrivent des bouquins, qui oublient
de payer leurs impôts, qui sont obligés
de faire des piges à côté, tout ça, ça
existe. Donc faut pas le faut pas le
cacher.
Bcher Cher Salé, c'est qui ? C'était le
diarcam du président de la Libye enfin
de Kaddafi.
Il est arrivé tout seul en Afrique.
Oui. Vous savez pourquoi ?
Avec ses petites mains.
Absolument.
Il battait des bras.
Pas du tout. Il était il faisait l'objet
d'une enquête déjà à l'époque et d'une
surveillance. Mais de la part du à la
demande du qu d'ors déjà il faut le
savoir mais je me suis expliqué devant
des juges mais j'irai pas plus loin.
Deuxièmement il avait un passeport
diplôme nigérien. Ça veut dire qu'il
avait liberté d'aller venir au tit de la
convention de Vienne. Point bar.
Quand je lis et quand j'entends que vous
avez participé à son exfiltration.
Amenez-moi la preuve. Et quelle
filtration ? Parce que je peux aider des
diplomates
ayant des passeports diplomatiques à
s'exfiltrer. Mais s'exfiltrer de quoi ?
Mais on dit qu'il a mangé à côté de
François Hollande en Afrique du Sud à
une certaine époque. Et pourquoi il est
pas arrêté ? Je comprends pas. Est-ce
qu'il y a assez d'éléments dans le
dossier ? Je sais pas moi. Ça, je suis
pas juriste.
François Ruffin, ça vous fait penser à
quoi
aujourd'hui ? un député Capignon sur qui
veut peut-être dépasser Jean-Luc
Mélenchon voir concourir à la
présidentielle. Tant mieux s'il peut.
Avant il avait une autre vie
plutôt faresque.
Vous avez fait ses poubelles ou pas ?
Pas du tout. Je sais même pas où il
habite. Je sais même pas s'il a des
poubelles et s'il fait du tri sélectif.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi on a pu entendre que
Bernard Scarcini a a filoché ? Euh
pas du tout. Rupin a fait ses ses
poubelles pour LVMH.
D'une part,
c'est quoi cette histoire ?
Vous êtes très mal renseigné et celle-là
je vos propos du diable
vos propos n'engage que vous et vous
êtes à la limite je dirais d'une
diffamation.
Mais vous savez quand vous avez des gens
qui veulent s'introduire dans des
assemblées générales pour les perturber
et empêcher qu'elle se déroule alors que
c'est de droits et sous constat du C et
tout. Vous mettez en place un dispositif
pour empêcher les intrusions néfastes
comme Casino, Carrefour et autres. Et
vous avez des gens qui autour de
monsieur François Ruffin nous ont
informé volontairement. Donc je vois pas
du tout où est l'infraction
mais tout ceci est à l'instruction
aussi. Alors entre ce qu'on lit dans la
presse, les plaintes et autres, faut
arrêter des fantasmes.
C'est c'est
la presse. La presse ne fait plus son
travail pour vous.
Vous savez,
entre recevoir tout de go d'un avocat,
un dossier judiciaire
alimenté par une certaine orientation à
charge, bah ça vous évite 15 jours de
boulot, hein. Ça vous coûte quoi ? Vous
êtes invité à déjeuner, vous avez tout
et puis vous faites votre petit truc.
Bon, c'est de bonne guerre. Il y a plus
la presse d'investigation comme avant.
Média part, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
? Mais il y a pas fait son boulot. Bon,
des fois un peu trop à charge, il faut
comment dirais-je compenser. C'est c'est
son travail, c'est la liberté et tout.
Bon, des fois elle révèle des choses
intéressantes, des fois ça se plante,
puis il y a un peu de tout.
Mais faut lire toute la presse, faut
avoir une information générale, faut
avoir une ouverture d'esprit. Ensuite,
chacun doit faire son tri, c'est tout.
Mais on ne peut pas blacklister
d'entrée de jeu tel ou tel média. Faut
prendre, faut souposer, faut équilibrer,
faut faut lever le doute, faut vérifier.
C'est comme un service de renseignement.
C'est pas parce qu'un service de
renseignement va vous donner une info
qu'elle est, j'espère
validée à qu'à 98 %. Non, il faut
qu'elle le soit 100 %. Il y a toujours
une part de doute ou alors on le dit et
on met du conditionnel. Mais quand il y
a du conditionnel, ça passe moins. Vous
êtes fatigué ?
Non, pas du tout.
Est-ce que Est-ce que
vous avez de la rœur ?
Est-ce que vous vous pensez qu'après
plus de 30 ans de carrière, le fait
qu'on vous ait jeté comme ça, ça
Ah, sur la forme ? Non, mais le statut
le prévoit, donc il y a pas de souci à
avoir et tout. Tout était prévu, je
dirais emmagasiner, enregistré et tout.
Non, non, mais ça fait partie des choses
de la vie. D'abord, je suis pas le seul,
il y en a bien d'autres. Et quand je
vois ce qui leur arrive par la suite, je
suis bien content d'être à l'extérieur,
hein, parce que pardon hein les mecs et
c'est ce que j'ai dit à Manuel Vals.
J'ai vous avez votre ministère, il est
un peu light. Faudrait peut-être vous
entourer un peu mieux parce que le jour
où ça va vous arriver, il faudra
peut-être durcir votre entourage. Dit,
je vous permets pas. J'ai dis mais moi
je vous permets, je me permets parce que
j'ai une certaine expérience du
ministère. C'est le plus bel le plus bel
outil du gouvernement et il faut savoir
anticiper. Faut pas avoir un coup
d'avance, faut en avoir trois comme la
crise du virus.
Vous voyez la France comment d'ici 3 ans
?
D'ici
3 ans ?
Écoutez, d'ici 3 ans, il y aura des
élections bien sûr. Faut voir un petit
peu comment on va sortir de cette crise
pandémie sanitaire.
comment euh déjà au niveau de la carte
électorale, comment on va restabiliser
un peu tout ça pour avoir des relais,
des relais pour faire passer des
décisions centralisées mais en tenant
compte d'un plus grand discernement
local parce que la France
et on l'a vu avec la construction de
l'Europe, on a voulu supprimer les
départements, faire des grandes régions.
Là aujourd'hui, on est à cette zone.
C'est un échelon intéressant bien sûr,
mais gardons la proximité. Et
aujourd'hui, on a fait des problèmes
dans notre politique d'aménagement du
territoire.
On a à cause de la crise 2008 qui nous
est pas imputable mais que Nicolas
Sarkozi et Xavier Muska ont très bien
géré,
reste ça reste ça reste à discuter hein.
Oui, ça reste à discuter. Mais
le problème c'est qu'ensuite cela a
entraîné la politique de réduction
générale des politiques publiques et
fallait faire des économies.
Aujourd'hui, un hôpital ou un
tortillard, une petite voie ferrée
secondaire, ça doit pas s'examiner en
terme de rentabilité. Or, la Cour des
comptes exige que et c'est là où il faut
qu'on revoit notre système parce que la
France est une richesse.
Mais encore faut-il qu' du haut débit
internet et on le voit avec le
télétravail et autres, qu'il y ait des
communications dignes de ce nom et enfin
de l'emploi. On peut, moi j'ai servi
dans le département des Pyrénées
Atlantiques,
Messi Arudi dans les Hautes Vallées de
la Rudie construit le train avant de
l'Airbus 320 avec une unité de 100
personnes. C'est ça aujourd'hui la force
de notre France et il faut savoir
déléguer à la province. On est dans un
système qui doit être aussi décentralisé
et je pense qu'il y a une réussite et
bien sûr un côté souverain, il faut
refabriquer en France certaines choses
qui sont vitales.
Moi je suis confiant.
Snowdon à Songe. Qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
?
Pardon.
Snowdon. Edard Snowdon. Est-ce qu'on lui
accorde l'asile ? Alors pour moi,
Edouard Soden est quand même un lanceur
d'alerte parce que il dit des choses qui
que les services savaient entre nous. Le
problème c'est que lui,
on savait que François Hollande était
écouté par les États-Unis.
Je sais pas ce qu'ils ont appris hein.
Mais bon euh moi j'ai pas travaillé à
l'époque de François Hollande pour cause
mais entre la mer Calot. Oui, bon, on
savait qu'ils avaient une capacité
offensive, c'est une évidence biblique.
Mais Snowden, qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Il
porte au grand public ce que les
services de renseignement disent à leur
chef d'état en disant "Protégez-vous,
utilisez du crypté, faites attention,
chiffrez."
Et ben oui, mais personne l'utilise
parce que la clé de décryptement, ça met
45 secondes avant de se mettre en route.
Oui. Donc aujourd'hui, personne n'en
voulait.
Le réseau à l'époque Sagem et tout était
vraiment
horrible. Donc là le procédé Atos, tout
ça et tout équipe le réseau régalien.
Bon ça sent marcher mieux mais les gens
n'aiment pas avoir deux téléphones. Vous
l'avez compris ? Et on en revient au
toit de
l'ambassade. Il y a pas que ça. Pourquoi
les Russes étaient au-dessus de l'espace
cardin ? Vous voulez l'acheter ?
Oui, c'est drôle hein.
Les Russes c'est une menace autant que
les États-Unis.
Ça dépend à quel niveau. Niveau
militaire bien sûr, il surveille tous
les toutes les forces et déplacements de
l'out. Lorsque je vais voir mon mon
collègue du SVR
à l'époque,
donc j'arrive avec mes équipes pour
travailler sur des sujets déjà
préétablis et tout, euh j'ouvre la
portière, je descends devant le service,
il me faisait l'honneur de m'accueillir.
Il me dit "Alors, vous avez réintégré
l'OTAN, c'est pour mieux nous
espionner." [__] il a pas dit
"Bonjour le mec et déjà il me il
m'attaque en offensif et en agressif."
Bon, je dis ça va. Alors qu'au niveau
FSB, c'est pas pareil.
Voilà, on est on est sur différents
plans. Chacun a une mission différente.
C'est là où on apprécie les gens et on
travaille à la confiance.
Quel est le Est-ce que la France a des
amis encore ? Est-ce qu'il lui reste
vraiment des amis ?
Je l'espère.
Moi, j'ai quitté en 2012, donc j'espère
que d'autres ont continué. Je dirais
toute la coopération que l'on a mise en
place. Vous savez en Syrie, on a été
leader.
Quand Ali Mamlou me fait appeler en
disant "J'ai la liste des djihadistes
français qui sont sur le territoire
syrien, viens la chercher." Mais moi je
suis je suis plus au manette, voilà et
tout. Donc j'appelle Patrick Calvar qui
est mon successeur
qui me rappellera, il me dit "Oui, c'est
intéressant et tout parce qu'on peut
gagner.
Cazzuf dit OK ministre intérieur et Val
dit non on parle pas au à des bandits
comme les Syriens c'est une erreur. Un
service de renseignement c'est un
service de secours. Ça veut dire que
quand tout est bloqué la diplomatie et
tout on passe on passe et à gros débit
parce que c'est à la confiance. Et là je
crois qu'il faut arrêter les conneries.
Il faut savoir si on veut travailler
pour la sécurité de la France ou si on
veut nous plomber. Quand je dis en 2011
Quanton Arotte Farous Benabèes auteur de
l'attentat présumé donc de l'attentat du
C où la petite Cécile Vanier perd la vie
et on arrête d'oxas sa copine.
On nous autorise et les Syriens nous
aident à arrêter l'intéressé qui nous
arrive comme la cigogne
par la bande de Gaza et autres.
Et le gars nous dit les premières
auditions donc on a les visas pour aller
le chercher
pour le ramener en commissionatoire
internationale donc au niveau justice
française dit mais vous savez moi je
devais pas faire que ça je devais faire
un attentat au Bervilier un attentat au
Bataclan
on est en 2011 donc je dis faites-moi
une note particulière pour attirer
l'attention des pouvoirs publics et dire
le Bataclan est une cible parce que le
patron a attiré l'attention parce qu'il
défend chaque année au mois de janvier
l'armée israéliené.
Donc attention, sa clignote très rouge.
Pourquoi il n'y a pas eu de continuité
avec les suivant ? Il y a un ministre de
l'intérieur qui s'appelait Manuel Vas.
Pourquoi il a pas pris en compte tout ça
? Donc là, c'est grave. Donc moi, je dis
que quand on défend le drapeau français,
on le défend jusqu'au bout parce
qu'après on pleure. Alors, on peut faire
clignoter la la tour Effel tous les
jours, mais c'est peut-être pas la bonne
solution.
Il y a d'autres solutions. La solution,
il faut faire confiance au service de
renseignement et il faut en assurer une
fidélisation et aussi une continuité
parce que l'action de l'État varie
suivant la politique mais les services
sont une action continue et ça c'est
très important.
La plus grosse bourde des services de
renseignement antérieur c'était quoi ?
Il y en a toujours mais on ne parle que
des trines qui arrivent à l'heure. La
plus grosse qu'on a pas de dont on n pas
parlé. C'est ce que l'on m'a reproché
effectivement et à juste titre c'est la
fermera.
Mais la fermera, c'est quelqu'un qui est
radicalisé par une mouvance que l'on a
détecté. Ensuite, il exécute tout seul
et en action solitaire. Il veut surtout
pas mêler d'autres personnes, je dirais,
dans dans ce contexte, pour éviter que
des complices soient arrêtés et parlent
parce qu'il a choisi et il ininaugure un
nouveau mode de traitement. Ça veut dire
il est formé par des cours particuliers
en Afghanistan.
par des choses avec des des circuits que
l'on avait parfaitement identifié où
personne ne m'a cru. Euh deuxièmement,
quand il revient, bon il nous manipule,
c'est sûr, mais quand la première
affaire survient, moi on me parle de
l'extrême droite et je dis je suis pas
d'accord. Au 2è niveau, je dis alors là,
arrêtez vos conneries, trouvez-moi
cinq islamistes mais aussi cinq extras
de notes si vous voulez mais pour moi
c'est islamiste en radical donc il faut
me trouver. Et ensuite, ça bon c'est
dans les PV je dirais d'audition et j'ai
je me suis produit deux fois la cour
d'assise en durcissant je dirais au
grand dame du Pont Moretti l'accusation
alors que tout le monde soit-disant
m'attendait parce que j'ai dis oui c'est
un tueur solitaire à chaud parce que
dans l'exécution on va pas laisser le
temps d'expliquer d'où venait un petit
peu toute l'apprentissage dans les
madrassas dans la communauté d'Artigade
que les RG avait levé il y a très
longtemps que la 6PJ avait déjà
neutralisé Mais bon, c'est un éternel
recommencement.
Donc aujourd'hui,
quand je demande à être csaisi en
judiciaire par le parquet de Montauban
le deuxième affaire, on me refuse en
disant rester dehors.
Lorsque le samedi
la DCPJ me dit "Bon, on va solliciter
ton assistance pour passer au fichier
tous les propriétaires de 1143, les
fréquentations de centre de tir, enfin
la moindre les le côté logistique sur
lequel on pouvait et également les
adresses IP. Rendez-vous dimanche soir
20h. Dimanche soir 20h par fichier PDF
convenu à Étatmajor, je mets en numéro 1
la famille la mère qui était détentrice
de l'adresse IP sur laquelle la vente de
la moto s'était effectuée sur le premier
assassinat et je remets ça à
l'état-major de la DCPJ. Le PV sera
retranscrit le lundi matin à 11h30 après
l'assassinat malheureux de l'école
juive. Je pense qu'on aurait pu
peut-être se coordonner un peu mieux au
niveau parquet parquet d'abord et des
enquêteurs qui étaient à côté. Mais
secret de l'instruction et l'enquête, on
communique pas.
C'est ce que j'ai expliqué devant la
cour d'assis. C'est ce que j'ai expliqué
au magistrat instructeur. Deuxème 2è
point pour lever le doute puisque
Toulouse avait une analyse beaucoup plus
offensive par rapport à la centrale.
Donc moi tout ça j'apprends ça bien
après. Personne ne m'en avait parlé mais
peu importe j'assume la responsabilité
où on s'en expliquait avec Manuel Vas
avec Péchnard et Amori de HClock le chef
du raide aussi qui était responsable sur
place.
Quand je demande à 21 centrales
de renseignement étranger de voir que
vaut mera
les Israéliens me disent "Oui, il est
passé mais il avait un couteau, mais bon
sans plus et tout." Les Américains nada
et tout. après la tuerie de l'école
juive sur lequel on est arrivé un peu en
retard à mon sens
la NSA dit "Ah ouais au fait
l'adresse IP a été actionnée deux fois
ou trois fois à partir de Miramcha." Non
mais attends, moi on m'aurait dit ça
avant. Bien bien sûr qu'on aurait
judiciarisé mais comme l'a dit le juge
Trévén qui est quand même un peu sachant
en la matière, il dit "Mais moi, vous
m'auriez amené M avant, il y avait
rien." Donc voilà, on se situe dans une
zone de confusion où la moralité
l'emporte en disant "Vous avez merdé."
OK, on a merdé mais
le Bataclan, on n pas merdé aussi.
Je l'ai écrit moi en 2011. Donc quand on
me dit un attentat au Bataclan, je dis
"Mais merde mais attends qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait ?" Bon
aujourd'hui, je crois qu'il faut
raisonner en terme global.
Personne n'est sachant ou alors on peut
être bon un jour dans l'année mais il
faut tenir 364 jours. C'est ça
aujourd'hui.
Si vous n'avez pas une coopération
performante,
une amitié avec le service de
renseignement extérieur, des échanges
très performants, une confiance avec les
chefs de service, mais vous passez à
côté du truc. Et c'est là où tout
l'investissement réside dans la
continuité, la confiance avec tous les
services. Mais c'est pas gagné d'avance.
La continuité a été brisée là.
Comment ?
La continuité a été brisée
bah avec la révolte des printemps
arabes. Oui, d'une part parce que les
les les la coopération que l'on avait
avec la Tunisie qui a fourni le plus de
djihadistes au niveau euh comment
dirais-je des zones de combat c'est
quand même important.
Syrie, la Libye Syrie, chaque fois
qu'ils arrêtaient quelqu'un qui avait
une adresse en France, on purgeait.
C'était immédiat et H, donc c'était euh
donnant donnant. Donc ça ça allait très
bien.
Aujourd'hui, je ne sais pas quel est le
niveau de coopération dans la mesure où
il y a eu un changement. Les
instructions données au service étit de
ne plus travailler sur la mouvance.
Ensuite, il a fallu aider à la formation
pour qu'il récupère un niveau parce que
tout ceci nous intéresse en terme de
protection de notre territoire national.
Ce sont nos sentinelles.
Vous savez qu'en
au Maroc, il y a l'attentat à Marrakech
dans ce célèbre café sur la place très
touristique.
Le café de Paris. Non, pas le café.
Ouais. Non, pas le café de Paris, mais
c'est le sur la place très symbolique.
Ouais, exact.
Et
il y a des Français qui sont
malheureusement victimes.
Donc une enquête est ouverte puisqu'il y
a des intérêts français en jeu, des
victimes françaises. On me demande
de suite combien, quand, comment,
pourquoi. B attendez, il faut euh qu'on
aille en commission Gador International
et
lorsque
mes équipes sont prêtes à partir,
Émile Perz, le directeur du Steve
Service de coopération de DCI, enfin des
direction coopération internationale me
dit "Ah, tu sais l'attaché de sécurité
intérieure me fait savoir que le
ministre de l'intérieur est contre la
venue de français parce que entre
guillemets, je cite, "Ce ne sont pas des
africains et ils savent travailler tout
seul." Alors, j'ai dit, on n pas dans la
merde parce qu'il fallait qu'on ait un
point technique,
savoir si le président devait y aller,
le ministre aut. Il y a des choses, je
dirais, qui engagent le protocole et
toute la nation française. Et c'est là
où j'appelle
monobologue,
le directeur de la Jed service de
renseignement, Mansouri qui est qui est
très proche du roi du Maroc, qui gère en
plus le Front Polissario et qui connaît
très bien les problèmes d'Islam
américain. Je dis voilà,
je suis ennuyé parce que on me refuse 6.
Il me dit "Bon, c'était minuit et demi."
Il me dit "Écoutez, chers collègues,
je vous rappelle dans 1 heure euh
je rentre en réunion, ce qui était tout
à fait logique.
1 heure après, il me rappelle très
gentiment et il me dit "Cher ami, vos
gens sont les bienvenus et c'est
moi-même qui irai les accueillir à la
passerelle de l'avion parce que je vous
suis redevable."
C'est ça aujourd'hui. Il y a les
structures et les hommes.
Et lorsque vous pratiquez la culture
méditerranéenne parce que vous en êtes
issu tout simplement. Maroc, Algérie,
mon père est allé à Constantine, je suis
retourné sur les lieux, je suis descendu
à ta main de racette avec les services
algériens. J'ai été à la sé l'ermitage
du père de Fou des choses que l'on voit
pas toujours qui sont les zones
d'enlèvement les plus atroce
aujourd'hui. Bon tout ça pour dire que
si vous avez leur confiance ensuite vous
passez au-delà de la structure.
Ça veut dire que lui, il est passé
au-delà du la décision du ministre
intérieur marocain
et ce qui nous a permis de faire avancer
le dossier qu'on a résolu avec un syrien
qui avait été un marocain qui avait été
empêché de rentrer en Syrie, qui était
revenu qui a dit "Bah, je ferai le café
et terminé, je viserai le maximum de
nationalités différentes."
Et l'affaire a été résolue grâce à un
service étranger.
Quel
Canada ?
Et oui, c'est là où il faut gérer et
savoir gérer la coopération
internationale.
Seul vous êtes rien. On est bien
d'accord.
C'est tout.
Est-ce que vous voyez des choses à
ajouter ? Parce que on pourrait vous
tenir encore pendant 5 he voulez. Moi,
je je suis insomnia. Il vous reste
quelque chose dans
Ouais ouais, c'est bon. Mais il est pas
assez travaillé le Rom.
Oh merde, c'est un R du B, c'est du
gibolin.
Ouais mais ça va. Il
a consommé avec modération.
La modération avec vous, ça n'a pas de
limite
ça. Il faut pas
façon à minuit le carosse redevient
citrouille. Donc on arrêtera. Qu'est-ce
que vous avez des conseils à donner à
vos successeurs ? Vous avez des conseils
à Non non avant avant ça avant ça je
voudrais qu'on qu'on retraite les
journalistes un peu.
Ouf ! Oh les journalistes bon ils ont
évolué, c'est un monde qui a évolué. La
presse écrite est en crise hein. On le
voit bien
le côté virtuel a plus d'importance.
D'abord ça part en immédiat même non
vérifié alors que la presse écrite, la
vieille presse d'investigation, les mecs
qui collaient à la roue des services,
chacun était spécialisé. C'est fini.
C'est fini.
Ou alors ils écrivent maintenant des
bouquins sur leur passé, leur
expérience, les vieilles affaires, les
colcas. Mais c'est bien. Aujourd'hui,
d'abord vous voyez qu'un journaliste, ça
reste pas très longtemps dans le même
journal.
Ça fait le tour un petit peu de toutes
les rédactions et ça va, ça vient où on
passe de la presse écrite après avoir
tout plurgé le circuit pour venir à la
presse visuelle, télévisuelle ou ensuite
faire de l'investigation. Mais en terme
si le dimanche soir bon truc
d'investigation et tout. Donc c'est un
métier qui est en crise malheureusement
parce que les gens s'informment
autrement tout bêtement et les réseaux
sociaux ont cassé cette dynamique et
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien l'B qui va
passer je dirais sous des fourches
codines Altis
alors que
la Libé passe en association là. Oui,
bien sûr.
Altis Altis.
Oui, mais à l'époque quand vous aviez
Zamponi, Patricia Tourancho et tout qui
venait vous voir sur des dossier le GIA,
les les les la coupe du monde de foot de
98, ce que l'on avait fait tout en
anticipation, on avait neutralisé les
réseau, il y avait un travail
d'investigation.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un peu plus bas que
les sauf les gens qui ont le temps si on
leur donne les moyens et si on leur fait
confiance. Le meilleur journaliste pour
vous c'est qui ?
La meilleure équipe, le meilleur journal
c'est qui ?
J'en ai pas.
Mia part ?
Non non non mais ça tourne, ça change au
jour le jour. Chacun sort son son petit
truc. Non,
on peut faire encore confiance à la
presse.
Oui, bien sûr, mais à charge d'élargir.
Faut pas croire un seul une seule voix.
Je pense qu'il faut euh rayonner de
façon très large. Faut lever le doute,
faut se faire sa propre conviction, mais
faut refuser aucune information, faut
tout prendre. Façon dans la vie et dans
les services, on prend tout. Après, on
trie. Alors, tri sélectif ou non, c'est
là où ça se passe. Mais vous avez des
gens qui émergent avec une connaissance,
une expertise et voilà.
Ou une bonne approche, de bon contact.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à à notre communauté ?
Alors aujourd'hui, c'est le centenaire
d'Audiar.
Donc déjà
je verrai un petit peu tout ce qu'il a
dit parce qu'il y a des citations qui
sont magnifiques
et qui restent d'actualité.
Ensuite pour la partie renseignement,
la top bien sûr qui reste le must
de des services de renseignement et de
sécurité, savoir est-ce qu'on est
infiltré ou non et comment détecter je
dirais la menace et la réalité des
choses.
Et enfin, puisqu'on est en pleine crise,
Fit retourner en arrière
général de Gaul au fil de l'épée, un
chef,
l'instinct, une intelligence, capacité
de management, faire confiance à son
équipe. Un chef, ça s'apprécie comment ?
C'est parce qu'il est bien entouré.
D'abord, il est intelligent, il est là
parce qu'il est chef
comme vous. Non,
il décide. Non, moi je je moi j'ai fait
ce que je devais faire. Mais un chef, ça
s'apprécie à son équipe,
son intelligence à savoir déléguer et à
savoir déléguer à qui de droit. Celui
qui, même s'il est pas en charge de la
matière, mais parce qu'il a le bon
contact, c'est lui qui héritera du
dossier. Et c'est là où il faut faire
preuve de quelque chose qu'on apprend
pas à l'école et que m'a appris mon
grand-père, le bon sens paysan tout
simplement.
Et ça c'est le plus important, le
discernement.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer.
Ah, les jeunes d'abord s'ils ont une
passion qu'il l'exerce surtout parce que
la vie est trop courte, il y a beaucoup
de choses. On peut rentrer dans une
boîte le matin, elle est française, le
soir elle est américaine par une
procédée de fusion acquisition.
Deuxièmement, c'est la souveraineté
défendre son pays par tous les moyens et
partout toutes les capacités qu'ils
peuvent mettre
au profit du pays parce qu'aujourd'hui
on en a besoin. La mondialisation c'est
bien mais revenir à des fondamentaux
c'est pas mal aussi. Donc servir son
pays comme avant on le faisait à travers
un engagement, la fonction publique,
service national, servir un service de
renseignement, c'est pas mal.
Ça rend la France plus forte.
Bernard Scarcini, merci.
Merci à vous. Très bonne soirée. Ok.
[Musique]